salut salut dont je lance petit à petit
jeu mêlée on est tranquille où la
tranquille on est bien d'accord que là
où on en live c'est la chaîne twitch à
ce point jazz comme échec c'est ça c'est
ça on va suivre le numéro deux mondial
hachette avait vu la vidéo avec les
perruques l'alleud la vidéo un peu
ridicule vous avez fait sur sa victoire
contre contre manu star dans des shows
chaque fois vous peut-être d'ailleurs
vous est tout le temps dans sa mort
parce que les échecs de base c'est pas
le jeu le plus drôle du monde tu vois
donc ça donne envie de dire encore plus
que les autres
non monsieur klein faut se laisser aller
sur un jeu comme ça sinon ça devient
vite chiant complètement le cas mais
même pour nous en fait
enfin même saveur aux faits sionnel qui
vont si on tape à ses délires là on
ferait plus de vidéos à force je pense
c'est un truc qui m'a fait rire ce
week-end j'étais dans le sud pour
préparer le mans tome de la bd avec
gibbs en toc c'est julien tu vois et
pour patienter parfois on faisait des
petites pauses tu vois et donc je joue
aux échecs sur mon ordinateur portable
ils me regardaient parfois et je
m'énervais tu vois tout ce temps je suis
rapport qu il a fait ça j'ai perdu
autant alors que je le dominais tous
âges étaient à fond dans le truck voix
et à gibson taxi monde i am est en fait
forcément te voir jouer aux échecs qui a
compté comme ça faudrait que tu fasses
ça s'est régulièrement chez bcg pourtant
j'ai fait des live tous les week-ends
faudrait que vous veniez ah bon on
passera peut-être un de ces quatre vous
êtes qui sont là c'est plus marrant que
mais ils ont qu'à l'âge on taxer et
giggs ou intox il a 28 ans d'exil à mon
âge donc 25 les échecs parfois ça pour
un poil plus tard genre quand tu
dépasses la trentaine la région le plus
faire de sport absolue tu vas sortait
des fourchettes amer j'ai oublié les
fourchettes
sinon j'ai j'ai ça c'est une petit truc
parce que j'ai ramené des olives
et ouais donc et donc ils savent ils
connaissent un petit peu en toc c'est
guy dit les échecs genre des joueurs il
s'appelle maxime vachier lagrave tu as
quand même un français qui est numéro
deux mondial ou genre les gens normaux
ne sont pas au courant non ils
connaissent pas du tout quand je leur ai
parlé de maxime vachier lagrave bon ils
ont fait le jeu de mots basiques tu vois
comme ça comme tout bon
mais personne qui découvre son nom mais
maintenant mais par contre gibbs il m'a
dit qu'il savait jouer aux échecs donc
peut-être construit une partie lui - de
ses cadres pareil à julien le
dessinateur m'a dit qu'il savait jouer
donc on sera aussi une petite partie
pourquoi je sens qu'il peut être bon je
me dis qu'il n'était pas très bon mais
qu'il avait une technique pour me battre
c'est à dire me déconcentrer tout le
temps mais il fait plus de vidéos dans
le dessinateur ce que j'avais bien aimé
en fait ces vidéos par là ils la font
sur la bdla donc forcément ça va être
compliqué en ce moment j'avais mal joué
si j'allais reprendre pouvoir apprendre
à dessiner sa valeur hyper simple ce qui
expliquait c'est assez j'aime bien ce
qu'ils faisaient
ouais ouais bah il est très fort en
vulgarisation il est très fort en dessin
mais là il à fond sur la bd cos un peu
normal surtout qu'on a pris pas mal de
retard la passe qui s'occupe de faire
des dessins pour les nouvelles vidéos de
cyprien là donc ça lui prend tout son
temps à ce moment c'est un mec qui est
très occupé en effet alors c'est parti
c'est un homme d'affaires et que la
séquence déjà regardé la partie mais on
pourrait on fera on va essayer on va
essayer de faire comme ça alexis on va
essayer de se faire des wc d'un peut
suivre le match puis de se faire des
petites pauses à certains moments où on
parle un petit peu à côté
ce que 3h30 un peu long de faire que des
échecs donc on va essayer de chaque fois
je finis ma main comme ça on va te
garder en forme c'est comme le marathon
va faire des petits ravitaillement alors
avec les noirs donc l'iphone bissler
faut que tu saches que maxime c'est un
supporters de l'olympique lyonnais de
football je sais que tu es patrimoni
seulement parce que les vosges les
joueurs d'échecs sont fans de foot par
exemple avec ton copain aussi fabien
celui c'est bien dit que ouais voilà qui
est fan de foot
c'est drôle ouais il aime beaucoup je
pense que ça spécifique aux joueurs de
chaque demeure le foot me sont très
sport ils sont très forts ils aiment
beaucoup le tennis aussi la fabia est
complètement dingue parce qu'ils étaient
hier soir il a vu à des partis à new
york spécialement pour voir rodger
federer
et c'est vrai quand je leur dis c'est
damien le tennis non je sais que fuck
l'om ball tennis aussi avec fabien lui
sait tous les sports tous le temps enfin
mais il s'énerve mais des fois il est
insupportable si les verts ont perdu 6
saint-etienne a perdu layar ils ont
perdu contre paris le week-end dernier
tu sens qu'ils donnent mauvaise humeur
et dont alors ils jouent contre un jeune
américain qui s'est qualifiée de sa
saison il a le coeur ouais c'est un
gamin un des futurs 4 fantastiques qui
l'on dit possible policy les américains
ils ont une grosse une culture d'échec
la qui revient et donc pour le moment on
a une structure de pions qu'on appelle
benoni ça comme simplement quand tu as
des pions comme ça en dessin qui est
venu et des pions comme sans appel ça
benno nîmes on va parler plus en détail
mais en gros tu vois souvent g7
ce mec là donc que les qui allait en
rouge
il est en pleine forme lui il tape sur
la diagonale et tu aller quelque part
soutenu par les pions il protège le pion
en 2 5 de gens qui emploie mille deux
mois et puis ils sourient les pions
soutiennent les cases de la diagonale en
fait tu vois du fou éventuellement ouais
ouais bon alors là on pourra voir ce
qu'on appelle une répétition de coûts
c'est que tu vois vision qui fait aimer
le cavalier en f3 quand il met le
cavalier en live 3 maxi 1000 fois f5 et
exigeons qui remet le cavaliere h4 pour
menacer le fou et donc sa faute
à l'époque et bouge son cavalier en c3
parce que sinon le faux il menace le
pion en b2 puis ensuite la tour quoi
ouais et c'est pour ça qu'ils savaient
faire ça fait un statu quo situent ils
ont répété les coûts aucun de darbres
envie de gagner et ça fait comme ça
alors là on est en train de voir une
ouverture qu'on appelle la sicilienne
donc la cécilienne c'est cantal pions le
4 on essaiera de passer plus vite contre
le pion c5 qui arrivent et cette
position là c'est une position très
connu qui s'appelle l'ouverture nash
d'or
donc tu as remarqué que aux échecs on
avait tout un tas de noms à chaque fois
qu'on voit des ouvertures et un seul
pion que je change tout le temps en moto
sont
de confiance et non le pion aux quatre
toujours suis leur premier développé
ensuite le foulard en direct si jamais
ouais c'est un des trucs les plus les
plus simples à faire et un dvd meilleure
chose à faire au début et tu vois même
au niveau du numéro deux mondial ils le
font encore donc c'est tout à fait c'est
tout à fait juste et donc à toi c'est
les blancs qui ont quand même plus
d'espacé sur l'échiquier
tu vois tu sens que les pièces blanches
elles sont développées plus
naturellement que les pièces noires
développe le jeu de l'oie ils avancent
assez vite il a balancé un pion la roja
5 mai il a donné le pion b2 que tu pense
qu'il va gagner ici là ou pas le parti
la différence de niveau a les mots table
à mon avis ça va être va pas y avoir de
suspense
je pense que je pense pas qu'ils aient
beaucoup de suspense parce que parce que
maxime est juste 1000 fois plus fort le
seul micro suspense qui a ses sites us
et s'ils pensent que le match entre
guillemets trop simple et puis qui le
prend un peu trop facilement que vision
qui marquent des points au début et puis
qu'après ce soit serré parce que par
exemple la maxime il vient de sacrifier
une pièce il vient jouer très rapidement
le sacrifice est bon peut-être contre un
joueur plus fort il aurait pris plus de
temps mais là je pense que pour le
moment tout cas il est confiant il faut
pas que le sous-estiment quand même quoi
ouais c'est ça c'est ça faut pas qu'ils
sous-estiment mais bon à moins de le
sous-estimer les sections bien rentré
dans le match et c'est sinon je vois
jouer un gros score en fait je vois au
moins huit points d'écart perso ouais
d'accord tant mieux dans son sens bah
oui pour nous c'est plutôt bien ça veut
dire qu'on va le leur voire on va
regarder d'ailleurs tout à l'heure on en
parlera peut-être à la pause après une
heure et demie là quand il ya la petite
pause on regardera contre qui peut jouer
au prochain tour parce que dès le
prochain tour en fait tu auras que les
toutous meilleurs du monde
ça va être ça va être la guerre
pour une fois que je peux me mettre
derrière quelqu'un enfin pour une fois
que je peux me dire ah là je suis avec
lui parce que les autres bons il n'était
pas de ma nationalité donc je savais pas
trop marqué mon coeur penche est assez
facile
c'est facile et le prochain match il
jouera il jouera contre hugues riccio
que je pense mais on vérifiera et great
shuxin mes copains en plus pour moi le
prochain match sera difficile ce que ce
sera maxime qui est français et il joue
contre un de mes copains j'ai vu que
j'ai vu là l'interview avec maxime là
c'était pas mal fin d'interview il
expliqué sa dernière partie contre
carlson bret à rexel tient pas en bien
de temps dessus
bages et si j'essaie de regarder et
surtout de comprendre alors regardé
c'était facile comprendre c'est un peu
moins mais de ce que j'ai compris toi
aussi tu avais pas compris la totalité
de ces coûts quoi pas tout le temps
parce que c'est du très haut niveau si
tu veux c'est ce que je lui disais 'si
tu as regardé à la toute fin en fait on
discute un peu on rigolait fine charrier
pas en fait c'est moi qui moto charrier
mais j'ai si j'étais capable de
comprendre tout est cool de voir autant
que toi je serais pas là à faire des
vidéos
tu vois le jour et le jour et avec les
meilleurs du monde donc c'est pas c'est
pas possible
mais tu as vu il est sympa en plus d'un
maxime ça se sent non sur la vidéo c'est
un mec cool absent que tu as perdu mon
son
m'entends tu alexis je crois qu'on a
perdu alexis bizarrement j'espère qu'on
n'a pas perdu la connexion internet
alors on en a peut-être un petit souci
de codm a peut-être eu un petit souci de
connexion qui vient de moi j'ai pas si
alexis m'entends mais je vais relancer
en fait je sais pas si alexis m'entends
mais je vais relancer le live en fait je
vais relancer le live je vais peut-être
relancé live pour l'image de dexia a
frisé alors on va voir si ça vient de si
ça vient de la connexion d'alexis ou si
ça vient d'eux de ma connexion de ce que
j'ai essayé de vous mettre une bonne
qualité de flux en pensant que ça allait
tenir
donc on va voir on va voir
alors le temps car elles reviennent on a
un petit peu regardez ce qui se passe
alors maxime à donner une pièce tout à
l'heure et depuis joue très très vite en
action gavât a passé plus d'une minute à
réfléchir sur plus de trois minutes à
réfléchir sur son coup droit huit après
d'amd 4 donc d'un des cats a menacé le
cavalier le pion laférois 8 francs d'ici
c'est un peu pris briquet donc maxime
qu'est-ce qu'il a contre ça il a pour le
moment un pion il pourrait
éventuellement d'en prendre un deuxième
si besoin je pense pas que l'on puisse
vraiment se protège espions quoique
encore je pourrais faire f 6 ya le roi
qui reste pour le moment au centre et
j'imagine un plan com h 4 h 5 h si ce
qui va arriver très rapidement
je suis trompé on va juste rocqué pour
le moment mais en fait si on joue
quelque chose comme bref sept tours 8
bon c'est du blitz et en plus la
position à l'air quand même assez
intéressante à jouer pour les blancs il
va pouvoir éventuellement même envoyé
peut-être f4 envoyé le couvert h5 menacé
f5
il ya quand même des arguments à faire
valoir pour maxime et quand même il faut
faire un peu un peu attention parce que
parce que sacrifice de pièces il était
quand même assez optimiste et il
faudrait pas se retrouver dans le dans
le scénario où on sous estime trop
l'adversaire et que et que finalement et
que finalement ça se retourne contre
nous
alors qu'air france et 5 est-ce qu'on
peut jouer le coup à fond
5 c'est un peu la question qu'on est en
droit de se poser puisque f5 ça ferait
une fourchette 1 tout bêtement un pour
éventuellement récupérer une pièce mais
bon sur f5 peut-être que xu zhiyong
puisque faire sur f5 cette famille dion
glamies xiong
enfin pourquoi céder à miss a cédé à me
poser je veux juste rendre la pièce 1
mais comme maxime réfléchit à ce qu'on
fait il peut aussi faire d'armes
français 5 éventuellement fight for
ghana pièces de plusieurs manières
possibles
mais
intéressant intéressant tout ça bref 5
qui prend prend cette pièce là donc
j'aurais pu faire aussi propre y prend
dans ses 5 est maintenant en fait ils
menacent même en fait je laisse même pas
de prendre russie soit en justice
prononce la sphère dame français 5 et de
garder en fait la fourchette à venir
dont cavaliers ou 5
bon et maintenant on va devoir en si on
prend aussi s'en fait ce qui va faire
c'est qu'il va reprendre du cavalier
signerait le cavalier emprise mais il va
y avoir dame prend 2,5 puisque le
purifient sera cloué donc en fait il va
récupérer regagner deux pièces la maxime
sur warp réussissent d'un français 5
c'est fini et sur cavaliers prend 1,6
d'un emprunt de 5 c'est fini donc la
maxime va gagner la partie
alors sur la balle avec caméra des
joueurs aujourd'hui c'est que comme on
commentait avec ap sol j'ai besoin de
lui faire le partage d'écran et ça peut
faire ça peut vraiment créer un problème
au niveau de la connexion internet ça
fait beaucoup entre le stream le partage
d'écran la caméra d'absolu la caméra des
joueurs ça fait ça fait une surcharge
donc ce n'est pas ce n'est pas possible
on va récupérer absolvent allons leur
appel ça marche ça lui alexis ça marche
un interrupteur je suis désolé mais ma
connexion à couper d'un seul coup je
sais pas pourquoi
impossible de la retrouver ça nous
inquiète pas t'inquiète pas ça arrive
alors qu'il tombe au mauvais moment quoi
en fait c'est un truc bizarre parce
qu'en fait ma connection a commencé à
mal marché aussi au moment où tu as
coupé mais en fait c'est parce que je
regarde en même temps enfin tu vois je
suis connecté sur skype et je regarde en
même temps la partie sur taschen tu vois
pour voir aussi le chat enfin je sais
pas faux j'ai vraiment une collection de
campagne à fort bref mais tu vis un peu
à la campagne
ouais c'est pour sa collection de
campagne à j'ai pas beaucoup de débit
mais le chat en fait je peux le suivre
sur mon écran regarde je vais le mettre
là
ah oui bon j'ai pas j'ai pas besoin
alors d'avoir trop chaîne de twitch et
t'as pas besoin la chaîne switch est
pendante est partie maxime a gagné sa
première partie
bon
sans surprise à l'heure donc là on est
deuxième partie on est troisième partie
déjà la première salle effet la nulle
rapide la deuxième la victoire de maxime
et dont clara tu là on a là on à la
troisième ok d'accord pour l'instant
j'ai fait une petite pub sur snapshot
je fais aussi une petite photo sur
instagram pour dire que je suis là on
essaye de faire un petit peu de pub
partout
histoire que les gens viennent voir des
échecs mais moi je reçois parfois des
messages privés en liquide des gens qui
me disent oh je me ferais m'embêter je
suis venu voir un petit peu trop dernier
live déchets que ça me donnait envie d'y
jouer maintenant les joue tous les jours
ça fait plaisir
oui mais tata pas mal de gens en fait
ils pensent que c'est un jeu ennuyeux et
puis quand il commença à jouer ils se
rendent compte que c'est très marrant en
fait c'est parce que j'aime bien avec
les échecs c'est a pas de ta pas de
chance n'a pas le côté chance qu'il a au
poker ou quelque chose comme ça tu vois
mal ou même dans les jeux vidéo il faut
quand même juskila bouger la souris et
tout je sais pas comment c'est avec
warcraft chez qui joue pas mal à
warcraft warcraft pas si sage ou le
style à la souris au folk rock non non
pas du tout mais bon t'as les tatas les
points les level de tes personnages les
machins et surtout le temps que tu met à
jouer quoi c'est ça alors posée depuis
les échecs sa deuxième point positif
c'est que c'est un jeu qui est
indémodable en fait face à existera
toujours
ouais le plus vieux jeux phares dont il
ya chez moi c'est le plus vieux que ça
en fait
bon il ya eu des jeux il ya il ya des
ancêtres des échecs me cale on joue plus
et je sais pas si legault c'est plus
ancien que les échecs ou pas mais en
tout cas ça fait partie des plus anciens
jeux du monde ça c'est une évidence les
ancêtres des échecs quoi ils sont sans
les plus anciens jeux du monde mais les
échecs en eux mêmes ça s'est passé avant
le goût ou pas ouais c'était même les
éléphants ce2 les fous il me semble
exact le truc comme ça on pouvait pas
faire le rock
les pions une fois arrivé aux bornes il
pouvait plus rien faire enfin il arriva
résultat les parties durer des jours
apparemment ça a duré très longtemps
j'imagine le plus sérieux à la fin que
cio l'eau je fais quoi
alors on a une bonne colonne de la whey
à l'eiblen tu vois qu'ils attaquent pas
mal sur la colonne t ils peuvent
éventuellement prendre le pion des six
avec lecavalier
parce que enfin il ya une deux pièces
qui protégeront il ya que deux pièces
côté noir après donc seasiders pour
l'instant il donne une main avec les
blancs ils dominent mais s'est laissé
six et les sicilienne avec sa structure
de pions en fait tu laisses les blancs
venir par exemple les affaires dame
prend des six est peut-être on peut
jouer quelque chose comme damas 5 et
puis essayer après de contre attaquer tu
as été pièce sur un peu des flèches pour
illustrer away comme ça tu atteindras le
pion à deux lacs qui sans défense ouais
donc dans mon avis va jouer damas 5 et
puis il va essayer de de trouver du
contre je vois pas vraiment d'autres
coûts et tu vois il va être fait ils te
laissent rentrer en fait sûrs ils te
laissent ils te laissent avancé t pièce
site laisse monter à la volée entre
guillemets
et puis après tu le tue le contre
attaque en fait parce que ça a laissé
des faiblesses donc là sur damas 5 c'est
intéressant de voir ce que les comment
les blancs vont défendre avait il n'a
pas fait il a fait cas ici 6 il devait y
avoir quelque chose sur sur damas cinq
est là en fait la mauvaise nouvelle
c'est que tu vends rentrer dans une
finale donc la finale c'est quand il ya
plus de dames sur l'échiquier mais qu'on
a un pion de moins ça si tu comptes les
pions tulle et enfin pour compter les
pions d'ailleurs alexis je te donne un
petit truc c'est qu'en fait on se manque
et qu'il a plu sans quoi ouais mais même
quand tu es dans une partie que tu vis
de savoir tu vas tu utilises tu as pas
besoin de compter 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
tu peux juste regarder tu vois tu vois
çà çà çà çà c'est en face tu vois face à
face est en fait tu vois tout de suite
que les blancs ils en ont un de plus
c'est beaucoup plus rapide de compter
comme ça en fait sauf c'est à des plans
qui sont sur la même rangée quoi ouais
après si tu as des pions qui sont sur la
même rangée des pions des pions doublé
sur la même colonne des pions doublé
dans ces cas là ouais c'est un peu plus
un peu plus compliqué afin peu plus
compliqué lorsqu'elle est fou peut-être
mieux compter mais on va dire que quand
à papillon quand t'as pas de pions
doublet tu peux juste tu peux juste
compter comme ça en fait et là tu vois
les blancs ils vont essayer d'échanger
un maximum de pièces mais ils échangent
les tours il échange ils échangent tout
parce que son objectif ça va être de
rester tout simplement avec avec un pion
contre rien la fin et de et de le
promouvoir en dames et le fou est plus
puissant dans un espace comme ça là vous
lui reste plus qu'un faux et un cavalier
plus puissant que le cavalier
normalement la vitre est plus d espace
puissant mais en fait c'est que les deux
ces trois points mais qu'à la fin un fou
c'est 3,5 à venise 2005 un truc comme ça
ouais j'irai plus de 3,2 et 2,8 pour
être un peu mathématiques mais ouais
c'est un peu plus fort mais le problème
en fait c'est quand un pion de moi c'est
un truc qui m'a pris justement vlad que
tu as peut-être vu dans certaines de nos
vidéos
c'est qu'en fait le pion c'est pas que
le pion sais que tu vois ce pion il
contrôle des cases et en fait les miens
ce que le pion contrôle tu vois ça donne
un ça te donne un petit coup de boost
mais la bonne nouvelle c'est que tu vois
maxi l'aller les pions sur blanc et il a
le fou sur noir donc il fait un double
emploi etc l'autre il a les pions sur
noir donc à terme ça peut devenir des
cibles tu as éventuellement nom et sa
belle mort et comme mon adversaire a un
pion un fou qui est sûre noir ou blanc
j'essaye toujours de mettre mes pions
sur la couleur inversé comme ça je me
fais plus de soucis il sert plus à rien
le fond c'est çà et là en fait maxime
c'est ça aussi les bons joueurs c'est
pas que les ils connaissent les toutes
les stratégies éventuellement mais après
ce qui est dur c'est que bon nous on
connaît les stratégies mais demain on
joue contre maxime en fait on va jamais
pouvoir les employés parce qu'il est
tellement fort qu'il aura toujours les
coups tu vois le coude avance le coup le
coup de meilleurs coûts qui va nous
empêcher à chaque fois d'avoir nos
pièces sur les bas
gas cependant ici mettre son cavalier
hkd pour menacer le pion en rêve c'est
maintenant il peut faire ça exact il
peut faire ça oui avec ce qui'il peut en
fait mais après le roi va se mettre en 5
pour protéger le plan pour servir à
grand chose
exactement mais ça veut dire qu'il a
trois options de jeu pour venir attaquer
nos pions f 5 h 5
il a trois cases différentes qui peuvent
être embêtante et le problème c'est que
tu vois on peut pas du tout donc là
c'est moi qui bouge les pièces c'est de
l'analyse mais on peut pas se permettre
d'échanger le fou contre le cavalier
parce qu'avec le pion plus normalement
tu vas gagner la finale de pions les
finales depuis avec un plan plus gagnent
généralement est en fait il est là le
problème du pion de moins pour maxime
c'est que ça tu interdit de rentrer dans
les finales de pions c'est bizarre tu
vois pas ce qu'ils ont tous un haut
niveau et les voir jouer comme ça tu as
l'impression que c'est facile en fait se
battent de se battre contre maxime
vachier lagrave fait j'imagine que nous
aurons du rep
on dirait pas dix secondes contre lui
quoi il ya trop de les échecs quand tu
regardes des parties de haut niveau
c'est un peu comme un iceberg
nous on voit que la partie immergée mais
en fait en fait il ya beaucoup plus
c'est un peu justement comment parler
comme le comme le dip web les échecs en
fait c'est dans une prochaine vidéo tu
veux prendre une métaphore les échecs
c'est comme voir on pense aux coussins
faisons déjà 20 coude avance toutes les
possibilités
c'est ça qui fait que parfois il rate
quelque chose de tout bête qui est
devant leurs yeux parce qu'ils sont
tellement loin devant que en fait ils
voient plus qui ajuste la dans
l'immédiateté du coup j'avais déjà vu
des parties où c'était carlsen un lien
il sacrifier une de ses pièces qui était
défendu par un pion et le mec était
tellement à fond dans son truc il a même
pas pris ensuite la pièce avec son pion
à oublier allez connu cette semaine
d'ailleurs je sait plus sur quel final
c'était sa partie grâce à suis pas sûr
de voir la partie auquel tu parles mais
ça m'est déjà arrivé - personnel enfin
un truc tout bête quoi
il y avait juste ça à faire mais il
était tellement à fond dans son truc et
c'est horrible parfois ça peut arriver
et oublient de remanger une pièce qu
enfin ya quelqu'un qui te mange une
pièce et oublie juste de l'art manger et
là en fait maxime de faire un truc hyper
forte je vais te montrer voilà il veut
mettre le fou en b 6 et tu vois il a
réussi par un tour de passe passe
tu vois le roi il peut plus venir
protéger le pion ah ouais ouais ouais
ouais après sa main ce que tu faisais
tout et après tu ailles pions taille
pion qui a deux cases de dames et si tu
veux protéger depuis que tu m'aies
cavaliers à charles-mathon cavalier fait
quand même sacrément la gueule et on va
pouvoir se rapprocher avec le roi et
venir tous mangé un messie mais son pion
à chaque protégé par le cavalier après
il suffit qu'un arrêt non l'euro après
peu et qui va venir prendre le pion en
fait et je pense que maxime il va
peut-être même la gagner en fait ici les
noirs sont peut-être même les blancs
soit n'est mieux alors attention je dis
peut-être une bêtise c'est que sur fou
pour un f2 il ya cavaliers ou quatre
échecs pour le moment surtout problème
de attention absol37 la fourchette feu
la fameuse l'unique pour le moment il
peut encore reculer son rang l'ain pour
aller défendre mais bon c'est chaud
disons que l'essayer mais son roi en f5
pour éviter la fourchette après le pion
il peut aller en h1 puisse enfin il est
dangereux ce pont là c'est dommage qu'il
cette fourchette cette fourchette en
fait parce que s'il y avait pas eu la
fourchette c'était bon
gagné ouais mais avec des si on referait
le monde c'est sur mais bon c'est le
point positif tu vois c'est que le roi
de giang
enfin il me fait un peu de la peine
quand même fait un peu pitié bas il
était en d3 il était bien placé il était
heureux et puis là il
il est mal placé maintenant ce qu'on
veut faire c'est lui choper son cavalier
lui choper son pion je pense qu'il va la
tenir
je comprends pas ce qui fait en fait
quel est son idée j'ai pas tout compris
à ce qui s'était passé je dois te dire
j'ai pas compris pour il n'est pas pris
à parce que s'ils prenaient le cavalier
oui excusez moi si prenez le cavalier en
fait et qui reprenait et qui reprenait
une pure en fait juste pour te montrer
c'est moi qui me suis un peu perdu en
fait les blancs ils ont toujours un pion
de plus parce qu'on a donné un deuxième
avec les noirs donc il aurait réussi à
gagner avec son 3 compte deux donc c'est
pour ses 15 ans comme quoi un pion de
plus ça fait vraiment c'est vraiment
merde encore ouais c'est un problème
pour la devancer registre c'est un
problème de plus en plus et là en plus
tu vois si tu fais j'ai 3 pour passer
ton pions il va te changer conclut pions
et tu pourras jamais déloger le roi de
la case blanche en fait il n'y a aucun
souci avec le fourgon mais il n'y a
aucune pièce noire qui ne peut attaquer
ce roi donc en fait dès que tu va
pousser g3 il va te faire puis on prend
tu vas reprendre et après le roi en fait
ils bloquent le pion et lui de l'autre
côté il a un deux contre zéro qui passe
donc illégal et abandonna ses marques et
qu'elle avait abandonnée ouais ouais
les abandons abandon de maxime donc un
partout j'attaque or il a égalisé nul
oui non il a égalisé au score au début à
chaque fois ils connaissent tous par
coeur ils vont tellement vite
ouais ça c'est une position qui est
connu on l'appelle la finale de la
berlinoise c'est un truc hyper théorique
c'est très très théorique
c'est jouer au niveau depuis plus d'une
dizaine d'années
ça a été employée beaucoup employé par
crown milk et c'est une des finales les
plus étudiés à haut niveau la bonne
nouvelle c'est que normalement
maxime il la joue très bien puisque les
joueurs du top mondial de l'élite
mondiale ils sont
répondant cette finale et c'est possible
son adversaire il soit un peu moins
aguerris qui voit dans cette finale je
pense que normalement maxime il devrait
avoir le dessus dans ce match dans cette
finale pour ceux qui avaient suivi le
match de maxime contre un autre
américain da camera il s'était
complètement cassé les dents sur sur la
berlinoise de de nakamura
mais là je pense que contre construction
pour le vent je m'inquiète pas je
m'inquiète pas mais bon nous ce qu'on
veut c'est un massacre a là il me c'est
une bonne diagonale avec son poulain le
tu parles du fou g6 ouais mais il tape
le pion ces deux ont pour l'instant les
protéger mais après qui sait donc le jeu
le gros truc de cette finale pour faire
simple c'est que là tu as des pions
doublé et à cause des pions doublé c'est
beaucoup plus difficile de valoriser ton
quatre contre trois parce que s'ils vont
être plus difficiles a poussé que le 4
contre 3 des blancs de l'autre côté de
l'échiquier parce qu'il ya pas de pions
doublé en fait pour faire simple ouais
donc les blancs ils veulent prétendre
avoir un avantage à ce niveau là et les
noirs ils prétendent avoir un avantage
fin contrecarrer cet avantage parce
qu'ils ont les deux fous et que les
blancs n'ont plus qu'à en fait ce dont
parlait tout à l'heure avec la
différence de la vie delà de la valeur
des fous et des cavaliers en fait paul
ii le roi noir ne peut plus rock et la
pop contre un nom il peut plus rauque et
bacon ya plus les dates pour moi c'est
un gros désavantage c'est vrai quand il
ya les dames sur l'échiquier 7 $ d'air
dans tes parti tu remarqueras cantat
plus les dames sur l'échiquier c'est
moins grave au fond parce qu'il ya moins
de potentiel offensif
bon y'a des tours d'avancé et tourne
avance d'euros c'est que toi tu puisses
rocqué et l'autre pas ça te faisait
gagner d'être des tours d'avancé sur son
adversaire
oui mais c'est le cas en milieu de jeu
parce que laurent en fait il va se faire
vraiment attaqué par les pièces adverse
les en finale le roi par exemple si on
vient le cachant ses sept pour donner
une case un exemple bon ce sera pas
grave on aura doublé les tours et
finalement le rond c'est cette île sera
pas évident attaqué pour les blancs y a
plus vraiment beaucoup de pièces et en
plus il ya un peu plus proche du centre
et ont toutes formes parti tu as vu dans
la partie précédente par exemple comment
les joueurs ont ramené leurs droits au
centre à la à la toute fin de la toute
fin de jeu met donc en garde jeudi
toujours toujours ramener le roi au
centre à la fin toujours au centre à la
fin d'ailleurs il va pas le cacher ans
et 7 il va peut-être le cas chez ans et
6 on sait s'il sera pas si mal caché que
ça parce que le pion contre les cases
avec lesquels le cavalier pour l
attaquer et il ya plus de fous de cases
blanches côté blanc donc tu vois là ans
et 6 il peut pas vraiment être attaqué
s'il ya un signe un pari si
éventuellement mai
là il ya le pion en c2 qui est plus
protégé là pour le moment il n'a pas
pris je pense que si tu prends ces deux
ce qu'ils voulaient faire c'est par
exemple revenir là est peut-être venir
prendre ans et saint caprais ah ouais
ouais encore et peut-être les échecs
intermédiaires et tout ça en fait non si
tu veux le prend dans ses 2 mais voilà
peut-être maintenant tu voyais protéger
le pion c5 avec son roi et maxime dès
qu'il a fait ça il allait s'emparer du
fou justement pour protéger le pion ces
deux donc c'était dans l'idée en fait de
prendre ce pion ces deux c'est juste
qu'il a voulu un peu préparé
elle se veut prendre avant quoi maxime
en fait et cavalières f4 donc il était
tout le temps prêt à à venir à venir
s'échanger est ici finalement donc tu
vois on arrive là dans cette finale où
les blancs toujours un petit plus en
tout cas enfin après faut prouver que ce
soit vraiment bien mais bon t'as
toujours une meilleure structure de
pions ils ont toujours tu allais les
noirs ils ont des pions doubler les
blancs n'ont pas - ça c'est un avantage
soit c'est un avantage
après ce que c'est un avantage assez
conséquent pour gagner la partie ou pas
etc si bon on a toujours dit c'est areva
ferait des pions double à ton adversaire
dit là en désavantage
ça c'est de cesser complètement vrai
c'est quasiment toujours le cas en fait
c'est quasiment toujours le cas et c'est
plus grave ce pion lancé cinq passes que
c'est un pion qui est parti du centre
pour aller vers l'est donc ça c'est plus
embêtant que le pion g6 parce que le
pion justice au final c'est un pion de
l'ale qui est revenu vers le centre et
comme on a aussi appris c'est important
de contrôler le centre aux échecs donc
un pur doublé qui revient vers le centre
c'est un peu moins grave qu'un pion
doublé qui part vers l'extérieur il part
du 5 vers l'extérieur non là il a les
deux là il a tout fait
d'autant que les pions doublée parfois
ça fait des îlots qui sont au sol quoi
des lots de pions qui peuvent plus
défendre les uns aux autres alors là
c'est là c'est là c'est la totale là
c'est très grave en fait s'il n'y avait
pas le pion f7 justement la purée
recettes il fait un îlot n était pas le
pion f7 selanne hiver oui et tu
commences à tu commence à connaître pas
mal de petits trucs 1
attention ouais je regarde des vidéos
pas mal pas mal pas mal j'ai vu qu'il y
avait un air de détroit d'air dans le
chat tout à l'heure à eur23 tu me dois
mille euros c'est ton copain en fait tu
vas tu veux être raconte élise sans la
guerre de détroit et je regarde même pas
de chat en fait je regarde tellement
j'ai tellement focalisés sur la partie
je regarde même pas ce que ce qui se dit
là raconte rapidement si ce rally cars 2
r 2 et 3 c'était marrant bah je faisais
a comme d'habitude un live sur les
échecs comme chaque week end sur ma
chaîne de gaming et puis bon je suis pas
très fort je suis classé enfin fois
j'étais autour des 900 en cadence 5 5,5
quoi et je n'arrivais jamais à atteindre
les mille et je le dis donc je le dis
que j'arrive jamais attendre des 1000
que ça m'énerve tout ça et là hier de
détroit qui arrive alors après je sais
pas s'ils étaient là avant ou pas qui me
dit si tu arrives à dépasser les 1000 je
te donne 1000 euros donc les milles 1
mille lots sur le site recheche point
com et comme par hasard mais genre 20
minutes après je sais pas si ça m'a
motivé ou pas je dépasse les 1000 pour
la première fois et il était enfin je
sais pas s'il était dégoûté mais je
pense que ça l'a surpris quand même
qu'ils s'y attendait pas c'était rigolo
et d'ailleurs chose assez drôle aussi
g&g screen et après ce qu'il avait dit
sur le live j'ai aussi screen et mon
score et l'ofce ce point comme comme ça
c'est assez drôle les gens rompuy
retweeter oui c'était c'était c'était
super marrant ce truc-là lambus c'est
drôle parce que c'est vraiment une
question de motivation je pense tu joues
sur internet chez toi bonté en live tu
fous tranquille tu pour t'amuser
et tout d'un coup quand un peu une
carotte comme ça ça donne envie de ça
donne envie de puces te concentrer aux
échecs en fait c'est un hyper important
la motivation et la concentration
donc ça m'étonne pas personnellement
cette histoire là mais voilà c'est mon
gros problème je suis vraiment pas s'est
concentré quand je joue quand je joue
aux échecs
c'est pour ça que je fais souvent des
parties courtes d'ailleurs parce que
c'est là où j'ai pas trop besoin d'être
concentré à la différence des partis en
15 10 par exemple
oui parce que les répartissent par
exemple en deux un tu vois tu peux pas
réfléchir enfin moi en tout cas je peux
pas réfléchir donc c'est vraiment au
feeling et voix c'est celle que
j'apprécie plus entre guillemets parce
que bon pas besoin de réfléchir ça se
fait rapidement puis si tu perds bah
voila tu as juste perdu deux minutes
quoi plutôt que perdre une 15 10 bon
après je sais ce qu'on dit c'est mieux
de perdre une partie très bien que
gagner une partie nulle mais mais voilà
de toujours le plaisir de gagner
forcément c'est là pour t'amuser [ __ ] à
puce et ça ça colle plus au rythme de la
vie qu'on a aujourd'hui aussi je veux
toujours quelque chose à faire a pas
forcément tout le temps du tantad way
mans 2-1 tu peux faire plusieurs puis
hier par air 2 et 3 il a une chaîne
youtube aussi est il quand même déjà
fait des dons tiki up sol
ouais je m'en souviens il était dans les
deux dans les donateurs type ia très
lourd
enfin très longtemps je ne sais pas mais
y'a à mes tout débuts sur tipi ouais
c'était un des donateurs je me rappelle
il m'avait contacté par la suite par un
mail et j'étais allé faire un tour sur
sa chaîne j'ai regardé quelques unes de
ces vidéos mais que je connaissais déjà
avant r 2 t3 d'ailleurs j'avais 10 ans
mail que je suivais un petit peu avant
hier doté 3 ah oui c'est celui qui en a
qui en rose d'accord sur le crash avait
pas vus ouais en fait c'est ça en fait
c'est j'ai repéré tout à l'heure en fait
r2 d'être aussi là bas c'est pas écrit
pareil que sur sur youtube erreurs de
détroit merci parole enfin quelqu'un de
juste si l'argent dit tavis apps
ouais
depuis il me semble que je suis
redescendu 1
après josé josé plus rejoué parce que je
me dis non j'ai forcément redescendre
c'était exceptionnel cette journée va
pas être exceptionnel tous les jours non
plus jusqu'à 1200 1300 ça tu peux monter
petit à petit après ça devient c'est
bien plus compliqué je pense alors cette
partie pendant qu'on est parti elle a un
peu avancé et il ya un facteur important
d'ailleurs absolue comparé
du temps celle avantages autant de
maxime une minute 20 contre 28 secondes
alors il ya deux secondes de rajout de
parcours d'un crémant mais c'est quand
même une grosse différence donc s'il ya
quelque chose à trouver maxime il va le
trouver ici
cependant ce roi tu vois finalement il
n'est pas si mal placé au centre après
avoir maintenant menacés 3 avec un
clouage c'est pour ça qu'il a joué ses
trois pour éviter ces 3 est maintenant
est ce qu'il veut pas essayé de nous
chauffer le pion aux 5
une manière x ou y bien joué de la part
de maxime il menacé trois ils menacent
tout est fait en même temps donc il a
utilisé le le temps qu'il avait à la
pendule pour trouver pour trouver le bon
coup ou en tout cas pour trouver le
coupable est en difficulté elle sort pas
grand chose ce tour en achètent la non
lé lé pa elle est complètement passifs
sa tour après le seul point fort des
noirs en fait c'est le roi en c4 parce
que tu as par an si on prend vraiment
dans le camp ennemi mais il peut
rapidement il peut rapidement venir
choper notions et accompagner le sien en
fait tu as pour ça qu'on parlait tout à
l'heure du roi en finale et le roi tu as
quand y'a plus de pièces sur l'échiquier
ça devait une pièce à part entière il
fait combien de points le roi en fait en
fin de partie
alors on dit qu'il fait quatre points en
fin de partie 1 comme il est plus fort
qu'une qu'un fou qu'un cavalier en fait
et là on sent que c'est un problème ce
roi parce que là ils menacent tu as de
devenir note leïla plus qu'une tourner -
la pièce puis devient forte façon ces
séries là il va venir choper il va venir
chauffer le pion et maintenant il veut
se décaler poussé le pion à fond ici à
voile a plus rien qui lui empêche la il
est pas mauvais le gamin il n'est pas
mauvais le gamin on répète il a que 16
ans t'imagines 16 ans et je vous conte
le numéro 2 mondial c'est pas n'importe
quoi il a joué les championnats des
états unis c'est un joueur aguerri
c'est pas le petit jeune qui a jamais
rien jouer c'est un des plus grands
talents des échecs mondiaux là qu'on est
en train de voir ce petit jefferies et
c'est pas que carlson que vous avez joué
12 13 ans contre kasparov et qui avait
fait une nulle à un moment là où 14 ans
je sais plus si et kasparov était
complètement fou après
mais ça d'ailleurs que même ils semblent
ils s'emmerdent s'est levé tout ça est
incroyable regarde bien le roi c'est
horrible voilà là ils bouffent tout tout
c'est horrible mais c'est cool parce que
ça permet d'illustrer ce dont ceux dont
on parlait tout à l'heure ça te fera un
bon exemple
ces esprits possible pour la perdre un
seul à ses débuts quand même là le pion
en le pion et le fou qui se protègent
mutuellement ce impossible pour le tour
de d'ailleurs c'est bizarre qui bouge
pas son roi pour les déloger le pion est
il fou quoi vraiment le temps maintenant
si je veux faire c'est mettre leur en d3
et menacé chaque et mat et respect que
cinq secondes 4 3 olalala c'est vrai
j'ai le temps max maxime il est à 14
secondes
il prend plus de temps la web ce qu'il
est en difficulté il est sur le reculoir
et j'ai l'impression que c'est très
dangereux tu as s'y mêleront à detroit
il m'agace maths en un coup quand même
tout au tout
ah ouais là c'est fini j'ai bien peur
que à moins que maxime nous sorte un
tour de magie mais sinon c'est fini
ok mais l'eau qui va faire bouger 5
voilà il va me menace de soutien le pion
au balo grève a fait retour échec est
fou prend à a peut-être qui s'est sauvé
un coq quoique non il va chercher le
pion h
maintenant c'est bon il y avait danger
sur ce tour là où ils sont revenus à
égalité
ouais mais il va être plus proche il va
faire monsieur se bouffent champions il
est juste s ils attendent le prendre ok
c'est pas passé loin
beaucoup de chantecoq faut pas
sous-estimer l'optimum non mais il est
dangereux parce que là on est à on est à
2 partout et pour le moment maxime ici
se détache pas du tout on a combien de
combien de temps de jeu je vais essayer
de regarder ça si j'arrive à ya trop de
choses sur l'écran pour le quart d'heure
à tout à l'heure
mais on doit être à un jet à 45 minutes
on va peut-être nous dire sur le chat
depuis combien de temps ça joue ok il
faut pas qu'on soit des chats noirs
alexis celle là si maxime s'est fait
éliminer cons truction que franchement
parce que c'est possible déjà way est ce
que c'est est-ce que ça s'est déjà vu
que une personne comme ça que là c'est
comme ça arrive à battre des tops 5
mondiaux des trucs comme ça ce serait
une énorme surprise mais ouais je me
dirais qu'il a 5 % de chances de gagner
ou peut-être 2 % de chance quelque chose
comme ça mais bon c'est possible c'est
possible parce que guillon qu'il était
quand même je sais pas s'il est encore
dans le top 100 mondial peut-être mais
il a été dans le top 80 mondiale à un
moment donné déjà là il a juste perdu un
peu de classement mais tu vois c'est
vraiment un des plus gros espoirs des
échecs mondiaux 1 ce gamin ah ouais mais
qui est déjà dans le top 100 à saison
qu'il perd pas de temps il est il est
impressionnant ce gamin il est vraiment
impressionnant donc c'est pas le sens
qu'ils seraient qui lui apprend the
shack
je pourrais pas dire je sais qu'il a à
saint louis aux états unis donc c'est la
ville aux états unis où ils font
beaucoup de choses pour les échecs par
exemple carlson 7e kasparov truc comme
ça tu vas lui et c'est pas un mal connu
bon mais kasparov c'était cantine est
déjà devenu champion du monde déjà car
le sel avant c'était c'était un
entraîneur c'était un norvégien
je me rappelle plus le nom serait 2007
mais lyon xi si on doit fin c'est juste
moi qui ne sait pas qu'il entraîne en
fait mais c'est forcément quelqu'un de
connu obligatoires peut-être quelqu'un
le sait dans le chatt d'ailleurs c'est
possible genre si à fabien dans le tchat
ce qui est tout à fait possible il
pourrait nous dire alors une liste qui
reste cinquante et une minutes de 5 plus
de donc on est à peu près à mi parcours
il va rester quatre cinq parties en cinq
+ 2 et on va voir la fameuse partie de
960 aussi la haye ce qui serait pas bien
de prendre avec son full cavaliers qui a
eu cinq donc apprête à son pion en
créant des cadres qui va le reprendre
et après il avance ses pions noirs en d4
pour menacer le cavalier nature à bas
trop tard l'année mais s'en faut une âme
il s'en fout et ça aurait pas été
possible parce que je vais te montrer si
on fait un coup lambda
hazard en fait ce que tu veux faire
c'est ça mais en fait
lecavalier en le cas de la plus être
protégés par le pion et le carré
l'adverse pourra s'en emparer ok j'ai
rien dit non mais tu as raison tu as
raison pas n'hésite pas n'hésite pas à
surtout surtout demande quand t'as quand
tu as des idées quant à des questions et
ses demandes toujours parce que ça
permet de montrer ça permet de discuter
et puis parfois c'est des bonnes idées
parfois ceux des nouvelles idées mais il
faut que tu saches que même quand on
commente avec vlad des parties il arrive
assez souvent surtout quand on regarde
pas l'ordinateur que même là disent des
bêtises et il a était 18e mondiale donc
faut pas forcément voiture faut pas faim
tu as nous on n'est pas du tout [ __ ] on
a des idées on les dit on regarde ça
marche ça marche pas et après on discute
quoi question n'était capable de jouer
aussi bien que commenterai pas on sera
enfin de se battre avec vision gueven vl
et on serait là ce qui commande de
partis d'ailleurs les grands grands
joueurs ou ceux qui s'intéressent pas
trop le meilleur joueur qui commentent
au monde c'est un mec qui s'appelle
peeters vide l'air qui commandent des
partis pour un site qui s'appelle chess
24 c'est un site concurrent de
tchatche.com et ils commentent ils
commentent assez souvent et mais c'est
le seul joueur de très haut niveau a
commenté régulièrement avec le combien
ils étaient classés aux alentours de
2760 donc il était dans le top 10
mondial
tiens regarde s'ils pensent qu'avec son
fou il prend 1,5
qu'ensuite donc à le pion qui prend avec
son cavalier
il reprend ensuite il y semer en c4 et
ensuite se suivant les coulisses mais en
c4 et ensuite en
à la casse qui en d2 il fait fourchette
non je suis bête il ya le fou qui
protègent cette clause la dépendance il
vient jusqu'en c4 il sera très bien
placé s'il arrive en c'est clair ça tu
vois il aurait pu y faire une fourchette
avec la tourelle à la reine quoi il la
donne mais il aurait pu mais en fait en
deux c4 il aurait été très bien placé
quand tu es sur une bonne case comme ça
tu as souvent des opportunités bonbons
une des choses qui s'échangent là dans
cette partie qu'est ce qui se passe
vraiment pour le moment pas évident de
de dire a cependant il faut quand même
noter comme on parlait tout à l'heure
des îlots de pions que les blancs tu as
ils ont un pion salle en c3 alors que
les noirs ils sont bien regroupés
d'ailleurs il peut le promenant avec son
show ouais mais pour le moment il ya ça
qui s'est un peu compliqué paraguay
ouais mais bon ici prend à manosque est
malheureux il le fait et du coup si la
tourelle vient prendre la tour il aurait
repris de la dame
alors maintenant on a deux pièces
attaqué une ici une ici voici non avec
son fouet la toque e3 quitte à faire
comme ça ça fait deux îlots tu veux
pousser les pions pour attaquer non avec
son fouquet en cas en baisse at il
attaque le faut qu'ils en aient eu trois
comme ça le pion prend et ça fait deux
îlots tu veux faire ça le fou noir qui
embête at-il attaque
ah non j'avais pas vu désolé j'étais
passera bonne diagonale ce que je dis tu
voulais passer d'une case blanche et une
case noire en fait ouais voilà j'étais
déportation well as là en fait je pense
la seule solution serait de faire fois
ci ce que j'allais dire pour attaquer la
dame et pour sauver le fou mais le
problème c'est qu'ici
c'est très égal en fait parce que
brisebois pose me regarde il ya quatre
jours de chaque côté de tours de fou y a
plus grand chose sur l'échiquier
avec ce fou il peut prendre au moins pu
en loques eu deux là mais ce faisant
jouer ses derniers coups ses tours ses
limites donc il peut très bien le
défendre en faisant foi f3 par exemple
ou tour ces deux ça doit être tellement
classe que le numéro deux mondial te
propose une nulle quand même tu dois te
sentir honoré
il a battu un plus au club
alors on dit que j'ai fait xixe on y est
entraînée par baba cui à nakov s'écrit
sur wikipédia 2 tu connais non mais
j'aime bien le prénom baba cool y va je
me dis c'est encore plus classe je pense
que quand tu as tellement la classe
d'avoir un mec qui tentait sahel baba
cool y plus rien nada tu n'as plus de
classe pour alors une nouvelle fois 400
et ça s'est déroulé sur une pelouse
fétiche ça tu as souvent le voir dans
tes parties le ppu rica télé puis 1,5
bon c'est ce que je fais tout le temps
et en général et répond toujours de la
même façon un bon général je me fais du
souci quand ils rompent quand il répond
pas comme ça justement s'édifie tombé
sur un exter bas je suis tombé sur un
mec qu'il connaît quelques stars à toi
est en général j'ai jamais j'ai jamais
de tort
le mec à chaque fois il n'a pas bougé ce
plan là pour rien en fait mais bon c'est
le jeu plus durer tu sort des sentiers
battus au début et puis après parfois
les joueurs reviennent avec 4,5 en fait
ça c'est amusant bien il faut que je
commence à faire de nouvelles ouvertures
parce que je tourne en rond on la rend
ce moment je fais toujours la même
résultat la fin bas je me suis toujours
battre on nous écrit dans le chatt sept
chats qui nous décrit jusqu'ici égalité
c'est incroyable vas y résistent bien
on va peut-être avoir du suspens en fait
ouais je sais pas j'ai envie de te dire
heureusement si le match est sympa en
fait pas si maxime gagné à la fin j'ai
envie de te dire
mais si on a du suspense pour que maxime
perdent
moi je prends la victoire sans suspense
perçoit beaucoup aidé à bouger le pion
aux finances parce qu'il est protégé de
l'accord on a la même structure de pions
de tout à l'heure tu vois avec les
quatre pions comme ça les trois de
l'autre côté et les trois purs les pions
doublé allèles damage a remarqué avec
ils font souvent les mêmes ouverture 1
au championnat
la dose dernier à dernière derniers
duels que j'avais commenté avec toi les
mecs qui faisait exactement la même
chose à chaque début de partie
s'il rentre dans une ouverture et après
ils n'en sortent plus en fait
oh c'est ça quand ils décident et décide
quelque chose comme ça c'est rare qu'ils
changent à moins d'avoir vraiment des
gros problème car j'aurai des gros
problèmes dans ces cas là il peut
modifier mais sinon il reste ils restent
souvent dans le même territoire
on nous demande un peu ce qui se passe
suisse en bullet alors en bullet maxime
normalement et quand même favori joue
plus vite c'est un bon joueur de bullet
et moins y attend sur l'échiquier
généralement plus la différence de
niveau se fait sentir
donc normalement la dernière section est
les dernières trente minutes de jeu en 1
+ 1 normalement maxime doit être favori
mais bon enfin c'est un peu la roulette
russe faut pas qu'on si on arrive à
égalité ou un plus un mois j'ai peur
j'ai vu là dans le chat tu en a un qui
disait en fait tous les le top-15 se
valent en fait que tu que tu sois numéro
1 au numéro 2 est aussi fort olympio de
quoi entre le décès c'est le premier
quart les scènes qui est un peu plus
haut et après maxime ont entre 2 et 15
ça se vaut ce qui sonne les domine quand
même un peu tout le monde se sent
car la scène est un peu au dessus là il
est un petit passage à vide entre
guillemets mais bon sa maxime c'est ça
en fait s'il avait battu maxime dans la
partie contre maxime il aura encore
gagner le tournoi
karlsson donc c'est un semi passage à
vide on a tous des hauts et des bas
et surtout dire il y aurait dû faire
deux des trois corps et devenir pour lui
proposer 100 mille euros c'est laura et
des bas mais en plus c'est vrai mais 100
ch
je rigole mais en fait c'est le cas de
l'argent ma vie doivent gagner de
l'argent quand même c'est déjà là quand
même bien d'un tournoi mais bon j'ai pas
mis l'eurocorps carsed il ya une
beaucoup d'argent et puis en plus il a
les contrats de pub et tout çà et là qui
gagne le tournoi qui finissent
troisièmes n'y a pas une énorme
différence ça fait longtemps qu'il est
champion du monde à son âge c'est un peu
comme mayweather veuze mcgregor comme
quand tu pars dr kane tu donne beaucoup
de buts avait fait un petit tweet après
le match je n'ai pas trouvé le top ans
j'ai pas regardé en fête bat avait
l'impression qu'il faisait exprès que ça
dure longtemps quoi c'est possible
d'ailleurs bas fois mais dans ce cas là
ça veut dire que c'est ce que c'est
truqué ou pas je me pose la question
quand même beaucoup d'argent en jeu
après tout est possible
bah ouais ils ont tellement utilisé le
truc tout ce qui ne serait pas étonnant
alors on ou non nous on nous dit si ici
les jeux q si les joueurs peuvent
tricher alors déjà il faut arrêter avec
cette parano et puis en plus c'est pas
déjà vous voyez sur les parties que les
rectrices pas parce que je vous dis même
pas le temps d'être normale bon bah je
sais pas peut-être que des joueurs
spécialistes pourrait pourrait réussir
mais ils ont trop à perdre ils ont une
réputation il ya une réputation en jeu
c'est des joueurs qui sont invités je
vois pas un gamin de 16 ans tricher là
puis sont filmés par caméra tout ça
enfin je vois pas vraiment l'intérêt et
maxime numéro deux mondial pour gagner
un match sur internet enfin c'est c'est
juste qu'il n'a aucun intérêt à faire ça
donc son film edge 2 ouais ils sont
filmés au plaignant foscam alors on
pourrait les voir un fait ce cas mais en
fait ça ferait trop pour ma connexion
internet avec le partage d'écran etc
donc là on va rajouter mais oui on peut
les voir en faillite gamme
c'est pas truqué absolvent c'est juste
que mayweather s'est fait plaisir comme
le chat avec la souris moi je sais pas
moi je n'ai pas trouvé de papin en tout
cas j'avais l'impression qu'ils
couraient tout le temps c'est tout ce
qui me faisait liquoriste protéger ta
gratuits attirent un réel enjeu pour est
nouvelle dans ce tournoi finalement s'il
perd est vraiment grave pour lui alors '
si père s'est passé pas spécialement
grave mais il ya incertaine en jeu parce
que en fait les joueurs prennent ça un
peu comme le championnat du monde des
échecs sur internet du blitz sur
internet et donc c'est un espèce de
titre officieux honorifique et c'est un
tournoi qu'il ya quand même un certain
enjeu et il serait évidemment pas
content de se faire éliminer alors là
évidemment comme il joue quand contre un
gamin de 16 ans on n'a pas cette espèce
de tension mais dans le prochain match
déjà contre gries choo que va forcément
y aura beaucoup de tension beaucoup plus
déjà puisque de critiquer numéro 9
mondial et derrière si tu joues contre 1
carles scène où un haka murat ou quoi
gagner un match de 3h30 contre ces
jours-là cessé quand même face à une
vraie compétition sportive en fait alors
là ils sont lancés dans des échanges
comprends pas vraiment pourquoi
bon ok xiang à une tour contre d'une
tour est un pion contre deux pièces
c'est un matériel qui est éventuellement
légèrement al'avantage de maxime mais
comme les tours sont déjà sur des
colonnes ouverte
je pense que ça doit aller pour pour le
jeune américain une nouvelle fois
cavalli g3 il empêche à la tour de
rentrée sur la diam tu sais ça que c'est
important dans les finales de mettre les
tours sur la deuxième rangée au nom
pourquoi parce que c'est comme l'appelle
la tse la rangée de la bouffe
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de pions et que
ça permet de bloquer le roi sur la
première tu as y avait la tourelle
arrive là par exemple elle attaquerait
les pions et le roi il serait
complètement bloqué ce qui veut dire que
si une deuxième tour sera mené ça
pourrait faire un math de l'escalier
ouais et inversement pour les blancs ce
serait important de ramener la tour en
voilà il ya le fou qui est jeune c'est
pour ça qu'ils mail à tours en d2 tu
vois c'est pour pas que les bras de fer
se rendent sur cette colonne sur cette
rangée matin donc que tu peux appeler un
pour te rappeler le truc mais aux
techniques de vlad la rangée de la
bouffe c'est la dernière manche et de
bouffe hockey j'aime bien en fait la
rangée de la bouffe ça me fait marrer
lac titicaca il dit que le combat n'est
weezer c'est un peu comme si car c'est
une partie avec un mille huit cents lots
faisant lui jouant l'égalité gentiment
il faisant un match en cinq coups au bon
moment baez
j'ai eu l'impression que c'était ça en
effet un ca peux tu peux avoir des
consignes peut-être faut être gentil il
faut pas le faux pas le maté direct ben
j'avais l'impression qu'ils jouent l
endurance puis après il l'a fini champ
en deux minutes quoi il a peut-être
juste fatiguée un petit peu au début
bon je sais pas ça réfléchit je me
demande pourquoi il mais il doit ici dès
lors si elle rend aussi s'il veut faire
tourner des six échecs j'imagine non
tout reprend et caché leur ouvrage 3 ok
mais maxime il est pas enfin c'est
compliqué comme position parce que tu
vois les noirs ils ont un pion de plus
mais ici ça joue pas trop l'intérêt
c'est de savoir le premier qui va amener
son pion si c'est maxime qui amène le
pion aux anges et 8,6 et c'est lui qui
aura gagné et si c'est les noirs qui
peuvent amener le pion en premier en b1
c'est les noirs qui auront gagné en fait
en gros c'est une fois de la course la
voiture en son son pion sur le sur la
colonne je deviens pro tgv puis les
tours ont du mal à revenir tu vois une
espèce de les pièces blanches elle
bloque un peu les pièces adverse
ok donc là ce qu'il veut faire c'est
aller choper le curage de pour aller
choper la tour mais bon est-ce que tu
vois il peut y avoir des variantes comme
c'est un peu marrant juste pour
illustrer à une non parce que moi après
le progrès et après tu peux bloquer avec
le cavalier la colonne et s'il vient
pour te faire échec du bloc avec le
fouet en fait la tourelle peut plus
venir attraper le plus en fait ça fait
un blocage away from c3 peugeot va aussi
loin quoi c'est normal ça ça demande des
années d'entraînement d'hier direct moi
j'aurais pris sans poser de questions
ces experts en train de se passer dans
la partie ils font vraiment ça en plus
la wii
ils font vraiment ça et c'est pour ça
qu'il va pas tu vois il va pas prendre
la tour parce qu'il voit bien que si
prend la tour il va se passer ce que je
t'ai montré en fait don qui se décale à
l'idée c'est que si on pousse le cuir en
g7 qui veut ramener le rang f7 et tu
vois maintenant qu'il ya le pion en fait
ça bloque et tu peux pas accompagné ton
pions enfin tu peux pas faire tout rage
suite parce que tu perds le pion pas
s'il me sont fous en 5 exact il faut
préparer faire flouer 5 ce que j'allais
justement de dire pour protéger le pion
menacé tourache 8 j'apprenne à tour en a
chuté puis mais bon ça donne du temps au
blanc au noir pour contrer par exemple
enfin je sais pas après il faut voir
mais on pourrait peut-être contré comme
ça pour sacrifier du matériel mais
récupéré le pion bon à voir on va voir
comment ça se passe pour l'instant il a
gagné la course l'un savons il a joué
fou dès 8 ans premiers monts peu importe
la lauze fait le plan dont on parle
essai de contre attaquer le cavalier sa
force et maxime a ramené le fou en
défense du cavalier alors sois ici soit
ici il a mis 1 h 4 mais maintenant le
truc c'est que dès qu pouces il va faire
m la technique dont on a parlé juste
avant
attention bon pour y lever sur lui à
l'énoncé banlieue protéger mais il veut
chasser le roi et pousser les pions je
pense que le pion de maxime gagne la
course je pense qu'on va reprendre le
dessus alexis je ne peux pas le prendre
là non il le ballet sur les cases de la
colonne f non ils obligés de se barrer
et nous on va balancer nature angers 7
et c'est fini un homme mal je vais plus
que le tien joli hein ah ouais ouais
donc tu vois un lampion qualité plus
avancées étaient plus forts que 3 il
était trop loin il était trop loin les
pions moi ça finit là bas j'espère enfin
j'espère qu'on a pas à charge de
schiphol sais pas comment il pourrait
reprendre main il peut peut-être faire
ça il peut ouais le qui est peut-être de
faire fort qu'il se crée fait une tour
quoi mais bon
non non ça va le faire
ça va le faire j'arrive à sacrifier mais
bon ok normalement c'est très sain sagan
is normalement c'est les élémentaires
bon il va les abandonne pas quand même
jusqu'au bout tu as une chance sur 100
de la sauve et tente un piège il joue
s'ils jouent à fond mais bon je vois
vraiment pas maxime rater ça tu as la
dame et le cavalier ensemble en plus ces
deux pièces qui vous très bien entouré
sur lui reste plus que deux secondes
donc sofina même le temps et pas son
avantage je comprends pas vraiment
pourquoi il continue à jouer ici
franchement les manques à gagner mais
bon on entraîneur mur tu as me dirai
toujours qu'on n'a jamais gagné une fin
c'est une expression qui est connu et
qu'on gagne jamais une partie en
abandonnant mais après on vraiment on
m'a dit que c'était mal poli de ne pas
abandonner quand un n'avait plus trop
d'espoir quoi ouais c'est pas super bien
élevé mais bon là il ya encore enfin là
il est dans la limite a nié dans la zone
tu vois dans la zone dans la zone grise
lui reste trois secondes c'est celle
arrive à retourner le truc non mais bon
maxime réfléchit donc si ton adversaire
doit réfléchir c'était ça veut c'est
déjà un signe c'est à dire que c'est pas
si simple
je me sur ce troyen regarde la b1
fourchette à ça ça devait arriver
gg maxime on est passé devant on est
repassé devant la lui roulé dessus
oh là là ça va tellement vite au début à
chaque fois aimé qu'ils connaissent par
coeur
en fait ils gagnent même des ce boom
quoi ils jouent monde de secondes par
coup joué très très vite et je très très
vite a emmené en flattant les parkings
harry parler des différents son vrai
jour analytique et positionnelle comme
quoi alors ils disent et analytique et
pratique pas positionner leur a demandé
à blagues en fait sa définition
d'analytique je ne veux pas je veux pas
me porter responsable la définition du
genre et d'analytique parce que c'est
dans le français de vlad et je le ferai
on lui dira peut-être de revenir sur un
live pour expliquer la différence entre
un joueur analytique un joueur un joueur
pratique la ceni mais ça d'hommes en
bleu si ce prêt sont son cavalier angers
4 il menace le f2 la exact mais il fera
deux voitures se faire l'autre et ça tu
commences à bien le sentir je sens des
progrès par rapport à la dernière fois
tu commences à bien sentir le fait que
que en fait les menaces elles sont
toujours paré en fait moi ce que j'aime
bien faire en début de partie tu vois ce
que 4 puis après je développe cavaliers
fou et j'essaie d'attaquer le pion qui
permet de faire une fourchette entre la
dame et la tour et résultats donc
forcément lui bouchahda main évidemment
mais au moins moi ça me permet de
prendre une tour et enfin à mon niveau
en tout cas je tombe toujours une fois
sur deux sur un joueur qui avait pas vu
le truc tu vois tu as de la chance ça va
mais bon c'est parce que je joue en
absents quand c'est pas votre monde
avant qui est une menace qui marche
c'est pas évident voilà ça va peut-être
faire nulle part répétition possible ah
bon déjà avec toutes les pièces la
possible parce qu'en fait quand il fait
fou ou 3 maxime effet qualifié 4 pour
l'attaqué quand il fait pousser un il
ramène son cavalier f6 parce qu'ils
trouvent que son cavalier mal placée ce
qu'on appelle une répétition du coup ça
fait trois fois la même position que ça
fait nul mais en fait assez content à ce
niveau-là cantal et noir et que tu fais
nul tu es heureux en fait parce que les
blancs c'est un avantage
ce toujours en importance jaune et blanc
toujours bon après des fois tu auras ton
ouverture était pas mieux mais c'est
mieux de commencer avec les blancs sur
une pub son twitter maintient ce qu'on
est en sur ce live
est-ce que ça partage de partout et ce
qu'on ait beaucoup et s'achever sur moi
je sais que ton skype là donc je peux
pas te voir
on va voir on va voir avec avec les
internautes
grand maître glisse très bon je veux
quand même l'écrire aux abois marquez gm
sur autre chose points comme pourtant
non sa marque et elle m c'est un peu
moins fort c'est eux mêmes c'est quoi
ces maîtres nationale à grand maître
c'est comme ça ça aille plus on et 343
allez c'est pas énorme pour et on
pourrait réussir à être allés 500 pour
le match de maxime ce serait sympa
surtout que le match n'est pas si simple
qu'on aurait pu le penser alexis non
mais tant mieux dans son sens on
s'ennuie pas même sans ce feu un peu de
suspens
ouais alors c'est de nouveau la même la
même ouverture comme tu quand tu
reviendras de noms mais je regarde en
même temps mais attention les mêmes
structures de pions
up sur la page facebook sur le compte
twitter puisque naples atteint samedi
j'avais déjà fait voilà ça va ramener du
monde traite à bruxelles qui tu peux
être que kevin est champion du monde
d'ailleurs même pas d'échec mois de mai
champion du monde de notre île et grand
maître dans son coeur quoi les orgues
j'ai vu un message la passer sur le chat
ou c'était un gars qui disait avec
toutes les parties de grand maître
international que tu commentes
maintenant tu dois quand même avoir un
sacré niveau si tu allais vraiment dans
les championnats en fait ouais pas
forcément ça m'a un peu aidé quand j'ai
joué en équipe c'est vrai mais le
problème c'est que je manque un peu de
pratique en fait comme je joue pas
énormément je manque de pratique mais je
joue de temps en temps en équipe on est
en deuxième division l'année dernière on
est montés la dépression dur en première
division
et c'est vrai que ça m'a aidé dans une
partie que j'ai joué ça m'a aidé parce
que j'ai ma partie m'a rappelé une vidéo
que j'avais fait d'une autre parti ce
serait cool tu vois pour ta chaîne que
tu trolles en solo dans des championnats
en physique tu vois tu fasses ça que tu
fasses ça sous forme de blog et que les
gens te suivre ton parcours voire situe
aussi tout le monde petit à petit c'est
que les gens suivent ton avant c'est
quoi le problème c'est aimerait bien
enfin j'aimerais bien pouvoir le faire
éventuellement mais ça demande beaucoup
de travail et en fait je suis pas trop
tolérants à l'échec en fait quand je
fais quelque chose je le fais tout le
temps à fond et tu vois si je le faisais
ce qui est peut-être possible un jour ça
va peut-être arriver mais c'est pas fait
un toit ce serait vraiment pour pour
gagner quoi
enfin pour gagner évidemment je viendrai
pas champions du monde mais ce serait
pour essayer de bien jouer en tout cas
bah ouais mais justement ce serait cool
je vais commencer à faire des vlog j'en
ai un peu parlé je vais acheter une
un micro sur la caméra ce que tu m'a
recommandé ça a l'air pas mal aux
comptes pas par contre se dit enfin faut
que ta caméra et l'emplacement pour
mettre le micro 1 je crois qu'elle a
assez des minutes chacun sait ça non
mais je parlais en une sorte de vis pour
remettre le micro dessus quoi ouais mais
j'ai regardé sur le modèle que j'ai ils
disent que tu peux tu peux mettre là le
micro au dessus de la caméra doit par
exemple moi j'ai acheté le g7 ex marque
2 tu vois c'est parfait pour les blogs
mais son seul défaut c'est que tu peux
pas mettre de micro externe de ce que tu
vois si tu veux un meilleur son et donc
tu fais quoi tu utilises un otage
utilise le haut parleur de du truc pas
trop le choix quoi faut que je vérifie
mais d'après ce que j'avais un peu
regardés sur la taille mais je me suis
je me suis pas trop j'ai pas regardé des
heures mais j'ai vu des photos des gens
dans l'est dans les google les images
puis sa cave et qu'il y avait fixé le
micro au dessus donc je me dis que ça
doit pouvoir le faire à y en a ils sont
d'accord avec moi dit des gens mais
l'idée d'apple
trop beau ni d'absolue espérons que kiev
que kevin au succès excellents conseils
à la nouvelle série tu nommes ta série
de blogs ouvrent tout j'aime ces titres
euros tout j'aime je ne traite pas être
aussi c'est vraiment sexy vertou jfr que
je le reçois ce jeu c'est soul et j'ai
peur que le ressort pas successfull
peut-être que je disais que je dis ça en
rigolant mais je suis sûr que ça
marcherait en plus sans sucre comme ça
championnat par championnat l'avancé
d'un joueur tu t'y as tu as juste envie
qu'il gagne tu vois il ya des il ya des
joueurs des joueurs de gaming qui font
ça avec beaucoup de jeux vidéo quoi ils
commencent du début ils augmentent leur
personnage et tout ça en vidéo les
joueurs suivent l'avancée de leurs
personnages c'est assez courant dans le
milieu youtube oui oui je regarde un
petit peu cradingue dit je vais mettre à
clash royal de toute façon cette affair
sûr que l'incroyable mais c'est
peut-être plus on parle de moi au nom
mairesse mais c'est juste c'est vraiment
beaucoup de travail
tu sais c
c'est toujours compliqué en fait c'est
les échecs c'est quelque chose de
tellement chronophage c'est vraiment
hyper son message c'est pas comme le
vélo pourquoi pas comme le vélo bon je
veux dire c'était fort un jour très fort
tout le temps non en vélo je pense que
non mais le vélo tu sais qu'on dit
toujours le vélo une fois que tu as
appris le vélo c'est bon quoi oui oui ça
énorme et les échec non parce qu'en fait
tu as toutes les ouvertures qui sont en
train de jouer c'est des ouvertures que
moi je connais pas forcément bien sûr
jusqu'à l'époque où je jouais c'était
pas c'était pas très populaire est en
fait petit à petit tu dois tu dois te
mettre à la page
elle va te mettre à jour bahia fabien
qui est sans arrêt en pls un os non mais
de votre four travail ouverture sur le
travail et c'est ricky lampes et alès
permanente
ça doit être chiant ça par contre
ouais tu peux jamais te reposer sur nos
lauriers quoi tu vas te reposer sur tes
connaissances fin un petit peu mais pas
trop et là tu vois c'est un peu la mère
des recettes partie qu'on a un peu
quitté parce qu'on a un pion - là alexis
encore non mais c'est peut-être pas si
grave parce que c'est des pions doublé
et qu'il a des îles un autre îlot de
pions et que notre houari peut-être un
peu plus vite sur son cavalier là il a
trois une ola ouais donc d'un côté c'est
peut-être pas catastrophique mais bon
j'en ai marre pourquoi tout le monde y
allait kev suis pas c'est par rapport
aux faits c'est ce que le me voir
rejouer ce sera donc tout le monde
d'accord en fait le monde est d'accord
mais je sais pas mais ça fait longtemps
déjà fax et ces femmes qui doit faire un
blog c'est lui qui joue
kevin ne pourra pas s'empêcher de
commenter ces parties très fantastique
mais pendant les parties
j'imagine qu'il donne plus les coudes
avance à son adversaire en commentant
vrai que je fasse des mini camps
d'entraînement est la plus faible a
proposé de me faire un camp
d'entraînement un camp d'entraînement
ouais enfin genre pendant un mois tu
vois on se met tous les deux
on s'entraîne ah ouais j'étais en train
d'analyser t'entraînes tu fais des
vidéos aussi parce qu'il a ça en vidéo
au début les mets - non non il aime bien
eu une chaude fob non non mais on fait
beaucoup de vidéo ensemble mais
maintenant ils aiment bien avant il
aimait - peut-être y prend goût à faire
des vidéos chez pas traiter tout de
suite aimé faire des vidéos ou pas bah
ouais ça depuis toujours la position de
l'audiovisuel qui m'a lansalot donc moi
la base en fait je n'aimais pas trop je
préférais les lives en fait les vidéos
ce juteux pas c'était pas c'était pas
fort mais en fait ça agile j'y ai pris
goût en fait maintenant j'aime beaucoup
en faire des vidéos mais tu te prend
vite goût hand ce sont ses parents
j'ai commencé à faire des montages un
peu un peu marrant pour les prochaines
vidéos doutes et questions c'est ça du
week-end oui vas-y vas-y pose là ils
peuvent s'échanger à facilement les deux
pions la série mais son pion en champion
blanc à être cinq
le tivoli et remplis après roy prend
tout à fait ça peut être une idée des
blancs d'ailleurs de liquider ses pions
là pour aller faire un essai il s'occupe
de l'autre côté qui est assez dangereux
parce qu'il y en a quatre quoi parce
qu'en fait on en moi c'est ce que je
ferai non mais c'est pas idiot en fait
parce que l'une des idées ça peut être
de faire ça pour essayer de tout liquidé
c'est à dire que tu vois après si tu
restes avec un pion et un cavalier
contrat roi est un cavalier contre un
cavalier en fait le cavalier peut
s'échanger contre le pion et quand tu
restes avec trois cavaliers contre roy
assaf nuls ah ouais bon lie ce qu'il est
en train de faire maxime il est en train
d'épauler son pion on appelle ça épauler
un pion c'est qui vient avec le roi et
tu vas 7 en fait tu vois ça fait une
espèce de tête et des épaules
en fait c'est pour ça qu'on appelle
cette technique l'a épaulé un pion sais
que tu amènes ton roi et puis tu essayes
de
tu pousses l'attention c'est bon là il
va les pousser jusqu'au bout je vois pas
trop comment il peut se faire arrêter
pourquoi ils n'avancent pas je mens pas
il va arrêter les pions noirs en fait
ouais m'enfin je lis ce serait le celui
qui arriverait le point qui arriverait à
faire une reine le plus tôt quoi n'était
pas méga concentrer le pas puisque la en
deux coups il faut certaines et l'autre
il le fait en trois coups et encore il
va soit arrêtée par le pion qui rend à
deux cas pour ça je comprends pas
pourquoi ils ne poussent pas un puits en
plus il le fait mon jeu je vais dire ok
parce que en fait s'il pousser les pions
je vais dire en fait l'autre faisait
échec fourchette et il n'est choper le
pion et après ils en voient ils allaient
prendre ce furent là non mais à part ça
je me serais fait avoir comme un bleu là
je pense qu à 900 lehman il faut pas ça
il faut pas donc là maintenant il ya que
des frictions qui peut gagner puisque
l'huile à trois pions et que maxime de
toute façon le ciri le père au prochain
donc avec un cavalier on peut pas mates
et donc normalement à moins d'un moins
d'un match exceptionnel
aidés par les pions noirs ça va être ça
va être son action qui va égaliser soit
maxime qui va faire nul mais ça me
paraît difficile
ça parle encore des blogs sur le chat a
en fait je vais faire des blagues
absent la raison si tu appliques solide
et ça donnerait à z trop tard ça
donnerait un intérêt au blog sur youtube
ça changerait des gros mots gourgandine
qui nous racontent leurs vacances au
combien intéressant tu vois ce serait
original en soins de plus en plus d'être
intéressant mais je vais essayer là
quand on va faire on fait un stage au
maroc et pendant le stage au maroc je
vais essayer syrie c'est avoir le
matériel adéquat avec les micros et tout
ça
je vais je vais essayer de faire un blog
ce sera marrant à la sat intérêt sera
vraiment pour la peine il faudra
vraiment la fin déjà tu vas tu aimes
bien ce qu'on fait mais là tu ça ça ira
pas à y aura pas que moi qui seraient
intéressés parce que suivre une personne
comme ça tu vois tu t'attaches pas envie
qu'il gagne pas c'est tout l'intérêt des
vlog tu vois justement ceux qui font des
délits vlog en plus c'est encore pire
parler les gens s'attache alors à ses
pairs à ces personnes comme si c'était
leur ami enfin je suis sûr que ça
marcherait touati si tu suis qui en
dérivent log est ce que tu suis des gens
non je ne suis pas de blogueurs mais ça
marche quand j'ai fait ma vidéo sur les
blogs
ok je me suis forcé à regarder des blogs
chose que je ne fais jamais normalement
et bien je me suis surpris à être
attaché à certaines personnes au bout du
compte c'est pas ton style de vidéos
normalement c'est humain tu vois tu
regardes une personne tous les jours
non-stop à la fin que tu le veuilles ou
non tu t'y la tâche tu vois et envie
qu'elle soit heureuse tu as envie eh bah
là pour le coup pour ton cas qu'ils
gagnent tout ça alors ton vélo garé ou
blogueurs préférés
moi j'aimais bien annie le jeu post tu
connaissais warta qui s'appelle une fois
il est plus connu sous le nom nous
attaquent
je connais pas je développe assez sympa
pilat en plus en ce moment il fait des
trucs assez cool avec des drones et des
trucs comme ça t'en sortir qu'un pion
mais il a fait nul à la partie
précédente et les siens ont réussi à
arrêter les pions à les pions noirs
le numéro 2 cherche à fair mule mais il
est il et il est fort le gamin en face
on rigole on rigole mais c'est parce que
je dois faire ça dénote d'un grand
talent quand même parce que tenir contre
maxime en 5 plus deux comme ça c'est
face à ces impressionnants fait ce qu'il
fait pour pour son âge
même pas pour moi je fais c'est déjà
impressionnant de base aulas après tout
le peloton
c'est pour quand et où les stalles peut
attaquer son pion la lesage marotte
c'est du 7 au 14 octobre et ce sera à
marrakech mais je fais un blog
j'essayerai de faire un blog pour ça
mais bon on va pas jouer là pour pour la
peine bon là ils ont fait une autre
ouverture à la ils ont complètement
changé
c'était une genre des stands yassoua
palin est indienne avec avec g3 je sais
pas comment il trouve les noms à chaque
fois des ouvertures
c'est parfois ça c'est un rapport avec
un joueur parfois avec la vie nous ça a
été joué en premier
parfois c'est par un rapport avec quoi
il est né les nationalités aussi ce peut
être la plus que l'ile-de-france
française la défense ça je sais plus de
qui s'appelle défense française
l'écossaise je sais pourquoi s'appelle
l'écossaise la française je ne sais plus
le nom doit voir ça ça craint pour un
français de ne pas savoir ça on doit
pouvoir nous l'iran le tchad pour la
défense française s'appelle la défense
française pas siciliano si je la connais
ouais mais là si sienne c'est une de
plus que connu on veut de la wii c'est
le pion 4 et le pion à ses 5 après la
fameuse envie d'aller voir la chaîne ii
you virale mais je connais la chaîne ii
you virale en fait qu'ils jouent au
poker
j'ai pas si toi tu connais non je
connais pas non je connais bats toi ben
l'estrie mère de détroit
luc pitié il y en a un autre que je suis
aussi je puis comment il s'appelle c'est
un mec de 40 ans qui s'est remis aux
échecs méga mon niveau en plus donc ces
deux c'est assez cool quand j'ai vu
comment il s'appelle
il a très peu d'abonnés ce cas je
pourrais pas te dire mais
tout cas ce qui est bien avec lui c'est
qu'il a mon niveau tu vois on a un peu
le même vocabulaire les mêmes réflexions
certaines de tes vidéos tu vois je la
regarde presque tout mais on a certaines
je suis paumé quoi parfois vous partez
dans des trucs j'ai rien vu qu'on a là
on a fait une vidéo pronostics la
dernière fois les pronostics pour la
patte du monde puis simple jeu rémy
madame en en de là pour le coup à la
place tu vois pas ce qu'il aurait fait
eux deux et ensuite il aurait fait ces
deux l'aurait menacé une des une deux
tours elle aurait pu venir choper le
pion peu oui non je veux dire avoir des
deux mais bon il a pas fait parce que tu
vas regarde tu va choper le pion en fait
il fait échec ici et après il faut shop
la dame a way est la raison pour
laquelle il l'a pas fait ça même si d'un
menu était tentant en fait pour te dire
la vérité c'est le coût auquel j'ai
pensé en premier aussi donc pas renoncé
au mamco en réflexe je me suis mis alors
on dit que ça a été je la défense
française elle est dénommée ainsi en
souvenir du match par correspondance de
1834 entre le wat miss westminster club
de londres et le cercle parisien de la
régence à la première partie les anglais
ouvrir par quatre et les français
répondirent par le coup inhabituelle à
l'époque e6 d'accord on appris quelque
chose
bon je me coucherai moins bête ce soir
en russie par la même occasion
alors là les on a réussi à gagner un bon
duo pour une fois qu'on aura plus en
plus là c'est la bonne nouvelle
enfin mais bon
on marche sur un fil quand même parce
que tu vois les pièces noires bon ça se
peut qu'on s'en sorte bien ces jeux pas
être dramatique parce que les pièces
noires elles peuvent vite peut-être
revient avec la dame en d2 je sais pas
mais tu vois pour le moment nos pièces
elles sont quand même tout sur la
colonne à elles sont pas très bien
coordonnées
on a un pion moi j'y crois montrent
inquiètes non mais en fait je commence à
de plus en plus m'inquiéter en fait de
tout à l'heure j'étais pas super sérieux
quand j'ai dit que le match pouvait être
tendu ou quoi adata 10 5% même pas 2 %
ouais ouais
est-ce que ce pourcentage aurait
augmenté au fil des parties
je pense qu'au début on était vraiment
plutôt sur deux sur cinq est là on doit
vraiment être sûr un bon 5 6% parce que
il se défend bien l'américain bon après
maxime vous quand même beaucoup plus
vite je pense franchement qu'il a pas
pris super au sérieux sans sens sans
rigoler donc ouais si il joue plus vite
il va il va lui rouler dessus dans les
parties encore plus rapide que celle ci
un imagine j'espère en tout cas j'espère
bon on va se retrouver de nouveau avec
une course avec les deux pions là tu
vois qu'ils sont prêts sur les starting
blocks pour landrin plus là donc il ya
moins stressés par contre saddam est
vachement proche du roi c'est un peu
plus embêtant heureusement qu'il réussit
pas à combiner avec une deuxième pièce
tank à lait ça va tu vois là si avec son
pion qui est en eux cinq ils chopent le
pion en d6 sékou double parce qu'en plus
ça permet à la tour quai sur la colonne
eux de protéger la dame va être un pion
à ses proches de trucs sur ce qu'il a
fait d'ailleurs assez pataud qui
bougeait la halle 1 d'accord d'accord
c'est ce qu'ils font vraiment hockey
montrait bien et là en plus ce que tu
dis c'est assez vrai dans le sens où le
roi le roi noir en plus sûr à la dame
elle est là il suffirait que lecavalier
reviennent vers leucate et partent vers
f6 et ça pourrait devenir problématique
mais bon après c'est un combat s'il est
noir réussissent à gagner le pion des si
ce sera l'un vers s'ils vont rester avec
deux pions plus et puis après les purs
yvon fils est là c'est assez tactique tu
vois ça va ça joue sajou à la tactique
là bas il va être super chiant ce pion
là sur la colonne des lancers de devoir
sacrifier une pièce chaussures je pense
qu'il peut réussir à le gérer ce pion
mais c'est comme quand tu joues alors
stone doit kenya que tu as une grosse
carte à gérer et que tu arrives pas la
gérer sa meute enlève toute ta main pour
pour l'enlever du truc ça fait tellement
longtemps que j'ai pas joué à leur tour
bien faire six mois j'ai dû rater deux
extensions
ouais mais c'est ça qui est dur c'est
pas comme les échecs tapas d'extension
je défends un moment à leur taux mais
d'hectares est de trois mois et qu'il ya
de nouvelles cartes qui sort et que
c'était pas dans le truck bah tu as tout
perdu
c'est fini la maxime il fait un truc pas
mal tu voyais la saddam qui attaquent la
qui garde un oeil sur la tour il a un
oeil sur le cavalier et il a un oeil sur
le pion tu as il a des yeux de partout
mais bon comme là ils protègent plus son
cavalier hausse ouais mais s'y prend le
cavalier il veut prendre la tour ou
gagner là il ya beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de possibilités
différentes bas ou alors il a vendu son
pion ouais mais si la hanse option il va
choper le cas mal quand même
et puis après pour choper le cavale mais
je pense que si tu vois si tu fais
quelque chose comme ça le pion à près
normalement il doit pouvoir le gérer
peut-être il va mettre la dame en d2
pour attaquer le pion attaqué la tour a
mon avis tu le gères après
dick avait d'amd de aussi dans les coups
possibles est possible aussi dam des
deux c'était possible aux deux sacrés
fut son truc le web ce qui va aller
choper le carolo prochain en fait à y
sacrifier pour prendre l'autre après
parce qu'en fait si tu prends du roi et
or ont pu après le nord ne choque
tu prends la tour on va voir si on prend
la tour en fait je ne sais pas ben oui
s'il prend la toîle peut pas le mettre
en échec s'il prend ses trente cinq
épreuves cette ya je pense qu'il a fait
une erreur et du coup on a sauvé le
cavale voilà puis après c'est depuis on
voit en de 8 l'automne prend quoi donc à
mon avis ils s'attendaient à ce que le
roi prenne et qu'après il le met en
échec
il a peut-être pas dû penser au fait que
la tour pouvait aussi prendre le
cavalier quoi j'imagine tu sais c'était
aussi
t'imagines c'est difficile de jouer à un
tel niveau de vol mais qui doit être
traité de fou quoi ma vie à certains
coûts lambda qui lui échappe à cause de
la pression c'est ça c'est que si jouer
contre quelqu'un de moins fort
évidemment il voit tout ça mais là il
est sous sa fessée le match et lons a
fait plusieurs heures qui joue la dame
dames 8 échecs c'est fou que je pensais
qu'il avait joué aux coups précédents
donc il avait raté ça ils auraient pu
gagner un temps et la maxime en fait il
va réussir à gérer le pion avec toutes
ces pièces il peut pas il peut pas
avancer tu as il avance voilà il le foot
julin j'imagine que le cavalier va venir
en aide cette la tour en des 8 ou dan v6
bien joué ils contre attaquent ils
contre-attaquent maxime il va attaquer
de l'autre côté
et là il va faire car emile l'assomption
il le protège ce mois il y avait double
attaque sur ouï oui ok j'avais pas vu
que le tour et là on va être le pion 17
et gérer maintenant par le cavalier
exigeons qu'il a juste donné une pièce
dans le désert pour rien non il faut
encore faire un peu attention mais ce
flou comme le truc de feu demain c'est
la pression
comme quoi sature pas grand chose un
coup de trop et se finir
pas le droit à l'erreur des kits d'aidé
qui gère le plus indécis c'est qu'il le
mange c'est finis d'équipement ge le
pion des six la partie est terminée
là je pense qu'il va faire à 6 pour
faire des cinq chasser la dame est chopé
le pion normalement ça doit aller ça va
nous faire du bien de prendre deux
points d'avancé quand même avec un point
coop qu un point d avance
je crois qu'il en avait déjà deux mois
c'est pour ça que cette partie là ça va
nous permettre de prendre un peu le
large quand même deux points tu as
l'impression d'avoir un break ça fait du
bien bon
on est bien on est bien sipa préfet pas
à six il doit avoir peur peut-être deux
tours 8,8 soit quand même oui tiens
comme c'est fini a pris l'option c'est
fini bonne victoire alors combien de
temps il reste pour l'heure du mal à
choper le temps mais bon deux points
d'avance aller si on pouvait en prendre
un troisième là ce serait nickel ça
permettrait vraiment de faire un premier
vrai break
tiens on change d'ouverture et ce qu'ils
perdent des points à chaque match ou se
classe pas classe e bonds s'est classé
mais c'est un classement interne est
donc ça n'a pas grande importance pour
les joueurs non mais j'ose dire sur
leurs pointeuses points comme ils ont
besoin de points ils peuvent en perdre
ou à gagner mais bon ça l'est pour un
check point comme ça pas d'importance
pour les joueurs de ce niveau là en tout
cas sur sur un match là il s'en fiche
complètement
la seule chose qu'il veut c'est gagner
le match alors ces frictions qu'il a
changé d'ouverture il a pilé pas
retourner dans la berline
c'est maxime qui a changé d'ouverture il
est partout dans l'espagnol pour que la
berlinoise il a joué une italienne
c'est une autre ouverture l'italienne
qui est assez populaire mais je pense
que c'est ce que tu dois jouer toi en
tout cas sur l'économie son cavalier au
bord pendant 21 jours d'itt cavaliers au
bord cavaliers morin alors il a mis le
cavaliere bord mais parce qu'ils
voulaient et voulait essayer de
s'emparer du fou mais oui cavaliers au
bord il va le remettre au centre
internet pas pour le cavalier il va
revenir plus tard dans la partie on sait
s'il va pousser les pions qu'il a perdu
un tour alors ouais mais ça lui permet
tu vois le cavalier bloqués déjà ça lui
a permis de gagner un temps sur le fou
parce que les blancs voulait pas perdre
leur fou contre le cavalier donc sa
force et le foie avancé et ça va avoir
permis d'avancer le pion et comme ça on
va reverser cavaliers derrière tu vas là
il va pousser le pion et puis à terme
soit il remettra le carré ans et 6 soit
il continuera pouces avec le cavalier à
5 mais ça lui aura permis de pousser son
pion c
[Musique]
alors on va voir ce qui va se passer
mais lassé des positions qui sont assez
typique
ça ressemble finalement un peu une
espagnole n'a pas l'espagnol couverture
très populaire les maximes là il va
essayer de ramener ces pièces pour
contrôler la casse des cinq
éventuellement ramenée un carrier vers
fc actuel peut ramener un cavalier en q3
et peut-être éventuellement après un
automne f5
c'est soit que je pensais d'ailleurs
cavaliers qui arrive après sur un rabat
non il fou qui me l'a vu il empêche
c'est ça ce niveau là c'est dès que tu
as une idée il te tout de suite il te
plus hostiles là il le voit tout ce
qu'il en est
dès que je vois quelque chose il levait
à le voir automatiquement immédiatement
alors c'est la dernière partie d'échecs
en 5 plus de la prochaine ce sera une
partie de 960 donc notre jeu préféré à
jour truc je peux faire 1 960
mais le problème c'est quand 960 tu mets
au moins 5 minutes de recherche quoi il
ya beaucoup moins de gens tout jouer et
pourtant une cadence classique tu vois 5
5 ou 15 disent tu met un temps fou à
trouver quelqu'un quoi normal
malheureusement 960 j'ai percé amusant
j'ai pas testé les autres modes après
mais j'aimerais bien tester le truc où
il faut faire trois échecs et mat après
tu gagnes quoi le 3 échecs
ouais c'est marrant fabien est
absolument nulle aux trois échecs
je te pu le faire plusieurs fois de
trois échecs à seydou est d'ailleurs à
ce truc là j'aime bien toi toi tu aimes
bien tu feras tu sacrifies été pièces
pour faire des échecs pour faire des
échappées au final tu donnes tout le
temps en fait j'avais j'envoie mes
pièces et des échecs
tu peux essayer c'est assez marrant
comme je l ai partie se termine assez
vite ça dure pas ça dure pas très
longtemps là pour la peine ouah genre en
400 m qni quoi ça peut aller très vite
tu es parti dépasse rarement le 20e et
oui ça peut durer quatre cinq six coups
parfois même soit allé très vite
mais c'est marrant parce que quand tu as
déjà fait deux échecs quand tu menace un
troisième échec tu t'es sûr de thé sûr
de gagner en fait enfin ça peut arriver
qu'une menace
effects de partout et qu'ils puissent
pas empêché après je peux plus bouger
parce que sinon il se prend le troisième
échec en fait alors cette position un
peu tu en as cavagnan f5 qui bien parce
que ça peut être quelqu'un qui peut nous
c'est un leader d'attaqué quelque part
mais on a du mal pour le moment à
ramener d'autres pièces en attaque parce
qu'ils sont fous angers 5 qui bloque
bien et bon position est assez fermé
t'es tu y vas prendre après puis
récupéré la case des quatre pour un
cavalier
on va faire d'ailleurs un jeu de chaque
tube omnium ci ne peut penser tu
pourrais faire avec les dessins des as à
ce qu'on compte faire parce que dans le
tome 2 la con après pareille à une
partie d'échecs
donc on a inventé toutes des pièces
d'échecs typique sans rire elle espère
non change pas les règles on change
juste me disais comme les échecs d'harry
potter quoi se savait plus en plus
classe quoi j'ai vu que tu avais fait un
petit court métrage aussi autour du
thème des échecs
il ya très longtemps moi j'en ai fait
plusieurs courts métrages avec deux
chocs
il y en a un qui est peut-être plus il
ya plus d'échecs que dans les autres tu
as deux courts métrages beau se dérouler
autour d'une porte de chaque année 2
alors j'en ai dit voilà n'empêche
qu'elle a encore remis son cavalier au
bord mais il a gardé pour le moment mais
tu vas ya toujours cette histoire des
pions le pion il s'est un jour il va
être pénible suit la série peut vite
arriver en b2 quand même bah ouais c'est
pour ça qu'il met pas son cavalier en b3
d'ailleurs c'est après la tour elle le
menace puis après le presque cavalier
ah oui puis non il ya aussi la reine qui
peut prendre un gpu les mêmes qui la
reine pas ignorer tour bientôt reprendre
des 4 mais là déjà il menace de
au nom des cinq ans fait pour le moment
et toujours c'est au noir de jolie
freida me prends des 5 es là tu as
dommage qu'elle fout parce qu'une bonne
fourchette 1 ouais c'est pour ça en fait
qu'il enlevait tu vas y avait cette
position là si vous êtes à me prendre
les 5 avec cavaliers prend puis on prend
un cavalier hausse est expliquée manière
bonne fourchette
ah oui en plus chaque et matt hall a
fini sur finir sur une fourchette royal
à l'échec et mat
c'est pour ça qu'en fait il a reculé le
fou un f6 parce que maintenant ils
menacent à ok là c'est assez marrant si
tu fais cavalli b3 pour faire une
fourchette
l'idée des blancs c'est d'aller prendre
h6 prendrait prendre avec la dame
et ça ça a l'air assez dangereux parce
que ça me la smat bas après il me son
cavalier brian à déjà la tour en soutien
chaque fois mais le fou prend il veut
venir ici en achète aouissi ouais ouais
mais bon tu peux changer ma toilette
échapper encore à voir mais ils ont joué
comment il a joué tour 8 pour un peu
s'échapper je veux pas franchement ça me
prend b4 donc ils ont joué différemment
et de mort son cavalier l'heure il peut
plus nulle part la wii mais les protéger
pour le moment ouais je veux dire s'il
veut bouger
oui mais les noirs ont gagné parce qu'en
fait ce qui se passe c'est que j'en
donne rien il y avait la tour emprise
bon on peut pas revenir mais en fait
j'avais la tour de maxime emprise et la
dame emprise fois toutes les pièces de
maxime et en mai ils étaient payés il
était pas bien maxime dans cette partie
c'est les noirs avaient trop de pièces
bien placé le quart eli qui peut menacer
les fourchettes le pionnier des proches
de dames
donc il ya plus qu'un point d'écart de
nouveau et la partie de 960 en 1960
c'est l'occasion pour toi de renouer
avec le jeu lors et moi ce que j'aime
bien avec les 960 sais que je suis un
joueur qui connaît aucune aucune
ouverture parker tu vois donc au moins
ou 960 on part sur armes égales on va
dire ça regarde c'est pareil s'il fait
ils attaquent directement le pion à 2 ar
oui ça c'est juste eu peut voir qu'en
960 parce que d'habitude aux échecs
talent à tour en 1 qui protège sauf que
la sirène avait bloqué maintenant la
question c'est ce qu'il est les blancs
ils veulent faire de troyes et tours 2
et s'ils font ça en fait la dame noire
elle est complètement bloqué il peut la
perdre en deux coups en fait la dame je
sais même pas s'il peut la sauver en
fait
on va voir
jeu honnêtement absolue je sais pas peu
dire j'imagine 3 j'ai l'impression qu'il
a fait une erreur en fait un joueur sans
quoi il allait manger ce qu'ils ont
rapidement et lapins c'est ce qui est en
train de se passer en fait il vient de
faire trois il veut faire tour de est
allé prendre la main tout bêtement tout
ça pour un pion la génération qui peut
enfin c'est très possible qu'on voit un
abandon là maintenant faite en direct
c'est mais ça ça va que tu vois ça
montre qu'il a quand même un peu pris
son adversaire à la légère
wi fi aux autres aux bottes
la partie a duré cinq coups non non non
c'est trop beau tout ça pour un pion qu
on pensait que c'était un bon coup mais
finalement on dire pensant c'est une
grosse erreur
oh là là à perdre une reine pour un pion
quoi il ya trois numéros deux numéros
deux faire comme ça qui perd en cinq
coups au nom c'est chaud après tu peux
dire tu voi le mec de saison il peut
dire voilà non mais j'ai battu le numéro
deux en cinq pots normal ne faisait pas
le poids ces trois frôle envie c'est
maxime fils il est marrant c'est un peu
un troll il peut trouver ben voilà il a
trop les un peu troublant c'est pas
l'heure cette icône peut-être qu'il ya
je demanderai à l'occasion s'ils
regardent des vidéos
c'est très possible très très possible
ah ouais mais il regarde pas mal de
choses sur youtube il est assez étonnant
il regarde beaucoup de choses c'est plus
sympa que j'arrive à faire une vidéo
avec le tien non en fait d'ailleurs
on n'a pas du tout parlé en fout quoi
mais peut-être peut-être qu'un 12
questions à maxime c'est peut-être
quelque chose qui serait jouable s'il
regarde ce que tu fais bah ouais je
serai titulaire serait intéressant à la
question numéro 2 de chaque mois je dis
pas non ce serait carrément s'il salue
en parler à l'occasion vous peut-être
fabien qui le connaît mieux mais ça
pourrait être carrément style carrément
plus en plus de lui faire de la pub ça
ferait de la pub aux chocs
ouais en plus ça continuerait dans ce
que tu fais déjà ce que tu as fait un
peu avec la vidéo de taëf et sur les
échecs et tout ça ça irait dans le jeu
sur toi qui en a le fait de savoir que
les français sont numéro 2 de chèques
ça leur donnerait peut-être envie de
jouer aux échecs tu vois je me sens en
rappelant qu'elles savent pas qu'on est
bien placé au zoo choc non plus en plus
on a maxime qui est numéro 2 on doit
avoir etienne bacrot qui est doit être
numéro 30
enfin on a des joueurs qui sont bien
classés en fait non plus maxime c'est
pas vraiment une exception la dose
joueurs qui sont bien classés mais bon
là faut pas leur montrer cette partie
par contre tout le monde se fout de sa
gueule dans le chatt 1 mdr tout ça
tellement ridicule mais je lisais en
même temps le chat là tu sais sur check
point comme tenant d'ailleurs je sais
pas comment il arrive à parler là dedans
mais tintin mini chat en dessous
l'iphone il souhaitait aussi de ça vient
ça arrive mais ça ça ça prouve ça ça ne
fait que prouver un peu la sensation
qu'on a qui n'a pas pris le match très
au sérieux la france la sixième ou
septième nation mondiale aux échecs avec
ses mille et deuxième dans web après
c'est quand tu prends la moyenne et
l'eau des meilleurs joueurs mondiaux
tu vois tu fais ils font une moyenne et
puis en bas mais bon en france on est 60
millions en russie sont combien c'est
pas équitable non plus c'est marrant
parce que numéro 1 il énervé il est
norvégien et le numéro deux il est
français donc en fait on est quelque
part on est devant les russes c'est
toujours leur sport national les russes
ou pas deux chèques moins qu'avant ça
leur devient un petit peu
pendant une période c'était a été
beaucoup moins dans ma femme qui est pas
loin de moi ne joue pas aux échecs mais
il son père joue n'est pas qu'à l'époque
c'est super beau la russie en visite à
moscou saint pétersbourg ce qui est
incroyable c'est que j'avais super chaud
en russie
comme quoi les préjugés elle était il
fait chaud ah ouais saint pétersbourg
tous les stands de quoi je chronomètre
chaud et en fait c'est attal préjugés
parce qu'il fait très froid l'hiver mais
en fait la différence de température tu
peux avoir
tu peux avoir du moins 35 l'hiver et du
+35 l'été c'est ce hallucinant alors on
a on démarre le 3 + 2 on démarre une
nouvelle une nouvelle cadence
je vais remettre le chrono il faut que
je le trouve déjà déjà maxime
enfin chaque feuille de niveau du temps
incitait le meilleur donc à mon avis
plus les parties vont être courtes plus
il va l'emporter facilement
enfin après je sais pas à notre notre
jeffrey x les pleins de surprises
apparemment je pense qu'au bout d'un
moment donné il va ce maxime vivas il va
se il va se chauffer à fond et puis la
vie il va dire fini les conneries mais
c'est ça évidemment il va dire bon le
petit le petit gong
il a du talent il joue pas mal il est
très très gentil il a toutes les
qualités du monde mais bon enfin le
ramener chez lui fin fond et montrer
qu'ils mettent maintenant
non hélas il a arrêté de jouer quatre au
premier coup il a mis à il s'est mis à
jouer des cats c'est à dire que ça les
ouvertures avec avec le pion roi ça l'a
un peu ça il n'a pas obtenu ce qu'il
souhaitait et il a changé
ouverture à l'est aussi d'ailleurs on a
oublié d'en parler mal et c'est le
moment de refaire des petits partage sur
facebook sur twitter
donc n'hésitez pas à mettre le lien du
du stream ont actuellement on vous vous
retweetez moi y alliant la danse que
j'ai mis ok tu peux vous pouvez
retweeter vous retweetez absolue ou re
fait ce bouquet absolument pas comment
dit sur facebook partager partager
absolue est comme ça vous voilà quand
même le numéro un français qui joue une
compétition qui est quand même sérieuse
et donc combien sur le live ans je sais
pas on va nous dit
on va nous dire voilà une petite finale
marrant tu es là tu vois intéressant
parce qu'on voit des pions doublé qui
peuvent être assez fort pour une fois
parce que il ouvre la colonne de la tour
sur le pion et qui veut essayer de
rapidement envoyé son pion verbe et cinq
ans fait donc ce pion là il peut avoir
une double utilité et quelque part tu as
la tour 1 elle est développée alors que
la torah 8 allée elle et elle est passif
parce qu'elle est bloquée à la défense
du pion pour le moment c'est pour ça
qu'il fait à six et là il va ramener sa
tour ans et 8 probablement pour éviter
des 5 parce que pour le moment menace b5
on peut reprendre du pied on sait mais
après fou prend b5 pourra pas reprendre
de a
parce que tu auras la tour bloqué c'est
pour ça que général à on enlève la tour
mais maxi il va ramener les cavaliers en
b3 et en a cinq pour attaquer le pion
bessette donc ça c'est ce qui va se
passer à l'est on est quatre cents à
l'est on est quatre cents allez on
pourrait monter jusqu'à 500 pour maxime
bonjour je retweete mon propre toute
assez pour le remettre d'actualité
tu t'es retweet ouais bon je peux pas
faire ça sur ma page facebook la parole
qui écrit si tu fais un disque élections
à maxime vachier lagrave il faudra que
tu poses la question qui tue est ce que
tu préfères voir lyon descendre en ligue
2 ou être numéro 1 mondiale parce que je
pars interviewé un joueur d'échecs pour
parler de foot quand même savoir la scic
l'interview quand même bizarre on se
demande aussi alors absents là quand une
vidéo sur les crypto monnaie je suis pas
le seul à attendre la série moi mais
c'est dingue il ya beaucoup de gens qui
qui attendent ma vidéo sur le bitcoin
quoi mais là c'est une des plus
attendues alors que c'est la dernière
donc il va falloir s'armer de patience
parce que je la ferai pas avant décembre
vous calculez alors je fais une vidéo
par mois donc il me reste encore partie
2 sur le dark est parti de 300 marques
web
après fonctionne la vidéo sur le dark
knight or et ensuite c'est bitcoin
alors maxime pour le moment il est assez
bien parce que tu vois hélas cavagnan à
5 qui attaquent le pion bessette donc
c'est un pion difficile à défendre parce
que c'est un pion de base
il est difficile de pousser le pion b
parce qu'il y aura souvent le pion sait
qui sera en prise et le pion à donc
quelque part ce cavalier il immobilise
la tour et il ya le fou qui vise la tour
donc le cavalier il est bloqué pour prod
tu as le cavalier en fait si tu
réfléchis bien il est là il est bloqué
sur cette casse parce qu'il doit garder
la tour qui doit garder le pion donc il
ya beaucoup de pièces noires qui sont
attachées les unes aux autres afin de
protéger ses pions si tu veux manquerait
plus qu'une autre chose qui me notion
obole le feu finalement ouais mais c'est
une concession mais peut-être qu'il
réussit à s'en sortir quand même là il
peut prendre le pion en ce 6 mai
quelques cavaliers valurent cran d'après
les premiers retours quoi ce qu'il est
en train de faire et moi ce fichu est
bon par rapport à ce qu'il avait on
aurait aimé qu'ils obtiennent plus que
ça parce qu'au final
au final c'est pas si folichon folichon
qu'est ce qu'on en a cinq pions contre 4
on a on a tous reppion contre deux
pièces donc ça à peu près équivalent
mais je suis un peu déçu ce que je
pensais que cette partie là ça allait on
avait un bon avantage et il en a encore
bien
bon il reste encore une tour là qui dort
un petit peu un faux nom est obligé
d'être là pour protéger le pion bon la
tourache transat est utilisée ont relevé
surtout un jeu 3d fait il veut bloquer
le pion h2 et attaquer latéralement le
pion aux trois a320 quelque part la
tourelle comme ça ce pion là il peut pas
partir aussi tiens fourchette au haut de
la fourchette
elle est là il l'a pas vu le jour cette
fois ci mais il a pris une pièce au
passage ça fait un échange en fait
c'était pas en fait ça va là pour les
blancs
parce que le pion b tu vois il est bien
avancé bon il ya la tour qui valait le
gérer quand même ce pion peut-être qu'on
va ramener le roi et ça devrait faire
nul normalement à moins de 1 - de
quelque chose d'exceptionnel ça devrait
faire nul alexis thomas kloet shot au
premier plan parce que les couper en
deux je vais essayer de cent des cadres
et ça recadre et c'est bien le même
intérêt
c'est là nul accord mutuel nouvelle fois
c'est égalité on n'est pas devant on
fait nul avec les blancs est ce que tu
as vu la référence aux échecs dans le
dernier patch du world of warcraft
non j'ai pas encore joué je veux dire le
patch qui est sorti aujourd'hui
j'imaginais quelqu'un qui écrit sale
dans le le chat web dans la région je le
connaisse c'est un officieux de ma
guilde c'est la guilde qui est là pour
la guilde deux abonnés ça va ils sont
bons owona bon après c'est pas une guide
de commandite de pgm comme on dit c'est
à dire on est là juste pour pour se
parler entre nous mais on fait pas des
des grands grand donjon ensemble quoi la
v1 discorde aussi quelque chose mais il
ya même là ils vendent paul j'avais pu
bas elle c'est une autre officière de
magalou très attention et mecs dans le
chatt syrie avait été décidé des super
héros de dewar histoire toute la guide
dobson gaming qui arrivent vont venir
nous taper dessus cet horrible alors max
il en a une petite finale encore
beaucoup de finales aujourd'hui c'est
une finale 2 qui sort de la de la
tchèque over et ça doit être à peu près
égales cette histoire soit à peu près
égales on reproche à maxime serait moins
bien même si on a des pions doublé c'est
pas très grave parce que ça nous permet
de faire une masse centrale moi je vais
prendre à son cavalier
ça lui permet d'user de frein printemps
ce qu'ils s'acquittent jouer se dévoile
en est mais c'est vrai que c'est que
c'est aux blancs il vient de prendre le
cavani à l'envers mais ce faisant moi
j'aurais fait l'inversé tu vois ça
aurait fait deux lots et abala de rester
très longtemps mais là le problème fin
le truc qui est bien pour maxime c'est
que même s'il a des pions doublé tu as
et le pion g qui est venu jusqu'en 1 5
donc ce pion là il était
oulala un entretien j'avais dit rien ne
fonctionne
c'est bon à l'idée c'est que sur cavani
prend à 7 pour choper les pions il veut
éventuellement mon avis faire tour ces
cinq pour venir enfermé le cavalier un
peu à l'image de la dame tout à l'heure
[Musique]
comme j'avais fait avec ladom de celui
que je vais provoquer en duel
alors dans l'ordre étaient là je me lève
toi ah oui tu te rappelles vous sans
faire exprès on pousse une belle
victoire de tapas aux enfants sur un
coup de chance parce que j'avais pas du
tout vu le nom fermement de ladom alors
il a mis le pion à installer un peu de
chance aux échecs
non mais a de la chance aux échecs en
fait même à haut niveau même si j'aime
pas la chance la chance dans tout je
pense dans la vie a pas de ja du as tu
peux dire pas de la chance c'est du
hasard mais à une partie de donc le
cavalier y va il a réussi à le protéger
grâce à son pion à 4 mais il a dû donner
le pion à et j'aime bien maxime l'a
quand même j'aime bien cette masse de
pion central
tu regardes être contrôlés bien le
centre comme ça aux échecs c'est une
bonne chose ça veut pas dire frileuses
trois rôles en commun
ouais mais enfin le truc c'est que des
trois îlots ça c'est le petit le petit
bémol mais le plus vraiment point
positif c'est que c'est difficile pour
les blancs de devenir s'en prendre aux
pièces de maxime options de maxime parce
qu il contrôle bien le centre pourrait
même faire flasher six échecs
éventuellement pour empêcher droit de
venir vers le centre mais bon il va
pousser avec ses 3 après béton et b3 et
ck3 ces deux donc ok tour des quatre
maintenant d'un feu et m'a fait retour à
imiter la lecavalier il fait un peu la
gueule parce que le pion b2i les clous
et donc tour des trois ils protègent
latéralement et peut-être ici
pourquoi pourquoi le clou et le pion à
la tour en face il peut l'avancer le
pion oui mais si tu veux si tu prends à
troyes le pion peux pas répondre ah oui
ok d'accord
obligé de tuer à la tourelle et elle est
obligée de protéger et en fait les
blancs ils sont un peu comprimé mais bon
c'est trois bien joué il veut à mon avis
et essayer de ramener sont renversés 2
mais commence à être agaçant ce petit
américain la fin c'est ça c'est ça
commence à 202 semble en fait non mais
c'est phase démarre enfin c'est plus
marrant là maintenant enfin vers fin je
sais pas faim commence à perdre les
parties j'en ai marre aux mots j'ai
espoir
du coup la guide de 120 s'envole et
guides lâcheuse toujours une la chose
well par tout le temps bon tout le temps
sous le temps des sacres mais il joue
aux échecs un peu dans la guilde ou pas
aucun des deux on y lit on en parle très
rarement
c'est pas une guilde tchatche.com tâche
sais pas si ça existe une guide ils
doivent y avoir une guilde joueur
d'échecs j'imagine avoir de la foire
kraft jeu pas mais après la discorde la
sinon c'est un peu la même chose quoi
mais sur dix corps nous on a notre
groupe discorde bitstream au hasard mon
avis tu dois en avoir plein après de
discorde se plus ou moins débiles qu'on
en fait et 125 quand même on se bat bien
125 jusqu'au mall je pense un peu le
seul discorde d'échec français aussi
donc c'est pas mal on se bat bien y'a
des mecs il ya des habitués viennent y
paris maître des exercices tactiques à
ils sont pas mal mais on a beaucoup dit
löw maintenant alexis il peut prendre
son pion leurs proches d'eux mêmes et il
va venir il va peut-être venir temps
fermé le fou où il va venir comme ça je
crois pour te récupérer h7
bon c'est quand même faisable
éventuellement mais il faut bien
calculer parce que si sur fourrages
dégager 3 et que le fou il ressort pas
ça peut être un peu chiant quand le feu
bobby fischer avait perdu une partie
dans son match contre boris manenti j'y
pensais justement cette fameuse partie
où personne n'a compris son geste
ouais c'était exactement le même la même
idée là il obligé de mettre son roi
serait colonne j'ai tout le temps quoi
pour protéger son pion non mais le x e 5
il est fort parce qu'ils contrôlent
beaucoup de casse ce mec là bas les
parfums à nager en plein milieu on a dit
il va falloir le chopper d'ailleurs avec
son son cavalier ouais mais ça va nous
il va probablement vouloir le faire mais
ça va nous permettre de ramener des
pions ensemble et de créer un pion passé
ah ouais c'est vrai que là trois lola
baï ne le fait pas un échec
ça peut être amusant à répétition
l'amérique est mais je commence un
américain l'uss de brûlures il se
débrouille vraiment bien je pense que
maxime doit être un peu agacé d'ailleurs
là maintenant à force parce que ça
commence à ça commence à bien faire
or le ramener chez lui non mais ce
serait horrible qu'ils éliminent maximo
premier sou enfin je serais vraiment
métro en pls jeux rétro au ps si maxime
je fais sortir parce qu'on a un tel un
beau un bon quart de finale qui nous
attend avec avec great chou contre
contre contre maxime et ce serait
vraiment dommage qu'ils se fassent
sortir par fusion qu'au premier tour au
moins on s'y attendre et paul quoi ouais
comme dans un épisode de game of thrones
tu as vu la dernière le dernier épisode
à dire qu'il faut maintenant attendre
je n'ai pas encore vu mais j'ai lu j'ai
vu ce qu'il allait se passer donc je te
veux spoiler non je me suis auto spoiler
est ce que j'avais pas le temps de le
regarder j'avais trop envie de savoir
en fait j'avais à peu près prévu tout ce
qui allait se passer d'ailleurs dont je
n'aurais pas eu beaucoup de surprises
ah ouais tout prévu non pas exactement
tout mais pour pas mon genre oui
je croyais pas du tout mais moi non mais
parce qu'en fait il ya un pardon mais je
veux pas spoiler les gens mais il ya un
truc que je sentais en fait c'est un des
trucs un peu je pense ya un gros truc
dont tu t'attendais pas et ça je l'avais
bien senti en fait et le coût du mur je
l'avais tout de suite senti à la fin de
l'épisode précédent en fait ouais j'ai
envie d'en parler mais je peux pas pour
poste paul et deux autres mais moi aussi
je vais en discuter en fait le bon pas
spoiler on peut pas spoiler n'ont tout
de même pas lui en place to be non mais
je sais ce qui va se passer donc quelque
part c'est comme si je l'avais vu dans
l'esprit tu vois tout ce qu'il va se
passer
non mais je pense oui mais plus j'en ai
parlé avec fabien donc ce que fabien est
allé voir en fait à new york il m'a
raconté qu'il y avait des parts ou y
regarder les séries en direct
un peu comme des départs sportif mais
des bars des bars série et donc il a
regardé la série dans un bar voilà j'ai
vu qu'à lever quelques vidéos sur
facebook tournée où tu as les réactions
de ces gens dansent dans un bar en
direct ça c'est drôle
ouais c'est marrant ça va être ça va
être fun à regarder
alors cette partie tu vois là peut-être
que maxime il peut aller fin c'est
risquer un mais tu peut parfois faire ce
genre de sacrifice à je pense que c'est
un peu optimiste mais pour ouvrir le roi
adverse et puis après essayer d'aller le
mater la barbare en ramenant terme ça me
paraît un peu optimiste mais maxime il
prend il ya forcément au minimum pensée
ou alors ils attaquent le cavalier non
il le peut pas elle a reculé mais il
peut peut-être moi je suis rétro tenté
de faire ce sacrifice même s'il est
mauvais en fait tu sais j'en riolo avril
avait déjà fait du yo yo avec les deux
des 960 là ok alors là je comprends pas
trop parce que l'outil peut carrément
prendre
je pense que c'est ce qu'on appelle un
mât ou type ok il aura un peu
d'attaquants corps et cavaliers des 5 es
fou h3 pour essayer d'aller mater mais
je pense pas qu'il ait fait ça
volontairement maxime
je pense qu'il voulait aller prendre le
pion achi c'est que ça sourira glissé
ouais c'est horrible bon il ya encore un
peu de juin peut-être c'est de mettre ce
cavalier a eu 4 mais bon il y aura foule
f5 il va tout défendre peut-être fou aux
quatre ici ce qui serait pas bien de
mettre une
une tour sur la colonne de la vide
ce serait bien mais on n'a pas vraiment
le temps parce qu'on a donné une pièce
bêtement et en fait si on prend notre
temps et qu'on joue normalement on va
perdre à la longue
donc là en fait quand quant à une
situation comme ça faut tenter le tout
pour le tout mais en fait il va juste
perdre je pense là je sais vraiment pas
même comment il peut continuer c'est
tout simplement un mât ou slip
tu penses que luc besson ouais je pense
que la soirée miss et c'est sur c'est
sûr il voulait prendre le pion à 6 comme
on l'avait comme on l'avait dit et la
souris a glissé bon maintenant il faut
essayer de sauver et de sauver ce qu'on
peut peut-être on peut faire je sais pas
ces systèmes ont dit c'est juste de
créer une menace ici mais ces pays parce
que le l'américain là il va prendre le
faire il va prendre les devants du match
en fait aussi avec son faux il prend le
plus en danger
6 il se fait reprendre prend enfin il
suit reprendre prendre un pion après la
dame prend échec
ouais ok nom est en fait le cavalier
protège sa il protège tous mais en fait
enfin je veux pas être alarmiste mais
c'est mort cette partie ok il tente le
tout pour le tout il envoie qu'elle
procède bien joué mais le problème c'est
que matériellement l'autre il a trois
pièces il a pas mal de matériel bon bon
elle a gagné un point de jeunes l'oedt
il a un point d'avancé mais il a surtout
souhaité partir avec +2 le problème
c'est surtout regarde regarde toutes les
pièces qu'ils contrôlent il a beaucoup
de pièces avec les noirs on écoute il
faut essayer de sauver un demi point
maxime il se bat bien mais bon il va
falloir arrêter la f1 c'est avec la
première fois qu'on est derrière dans le
match si on perd celle là est le
problème c'est que le match enfin il ya
de moins en moins de temps en fait plus
les parties avant ce mondial tendre de
de reprendre le dessus après voilà il
veut prendre son le pion qui en deux
sets je le vois mais l'autre il a tout
défendu il défend tout et maintenant tu
as le roi tu as le roi noir qui est venu
au centre tu as beaucoup de pièces pour
les noirs je vois vraiment pas à ça il
va il va pousser sur les colonnes alger
pour pour chercher la dame peut-être oui
oui mais il va faire ça mais les noirs
regardent ils ont beaucoup de pièces
pour gérer ça en fait ouais mais à un
moment ils vont devoir laisser la
défense pour aller à l'attack quoi
essayer de lala par exemple s'il met son
son cavalier en c5 l'échec courroye et
ils le il le prend avec le fou ah ouais
bon ils essayent de faire ce que
tunisair de pousser ses pions pour pour
empêcher à l'adversaire de deux places
et ses pièces mais bon normalement les
noirs ils vont pouvoir ramener mais
après ils me sont plongés 5
ouais mais le cavaillon h saint qui va
rentrer dans les trous non je vais dire
à mr qui veut dire la lfuq attaque mais
protégé par la tour à mal le prend au
caire oh là ou là ou là ça va vite là
bas il a regagné 1 point en plus ça il
est revenu à +3 l'a bien mais bon il
tente comme j'aime bien dire souvent ils
tentent de pêcher en eaux troubles
ça y est c'est de mettre une position un
peu bizarre et puis essayer de passer
les pions du nera x ou y mais
normalement problème c'est que
normalement ça va pas avancer les pions
la l'hautil mais il va mener la contre
attaque il a les cavaliers il a tout
bon allez il va falloir il va faire moi
je crois moi quelque chose
il croit encore dans cette partie il va
nous faire un truc inattendue déjà il ya
un minimum tourcoing f3 pro f 3 fou
prend 1,4 et fou prend h1 déjà qui peut
être pénible et après on sacrifiera
lecavalier contre le pion parce que le
curé cats sera attaqué deux fois ils
commencent parfois provocatrices et
provoqua c'est la deuxième option dont
je voulais parler
et là maintenant essayer de faire un
match avec les noirs d'une manière x ou
y est ça doit être possible
alors là qu est le pion enfin c'est
pourquoi il met pas son roi d'ailleurs
en f6 je pense qu'il ya un match ici au
caire roi ici cavaliers des trois échecs
roi des huns et tour d'eric harris et 3
matois jolie d'ailleurs le mat d'accord
moi j'étais focalisé sur la tour et le
pion oui et non oui c'est pour ça il va
passer les 2800 là il va passer de 1800
il a dépassé maxime au classement c'est
horrible voilà des incroyables et la
dépasse de maxime deux parties devaient
2720 un truc comme ça va à force de
jouer des parties et donc retournement
de situation non mais maxime je suis sûr
qu'il est très énervé là de ne pas
prendre le dessus
bon après y'a la coupe du monde et
surtout si la ferme aux clics quoi ouais
là c'est un mal aussi mais à la coupe du
monde d'échecs dans trois quatre jours
donc c'est sûr que c'est plus la coupe
du monde d'échecs le début qui qui
maintient sa concentration mais bon
c'est toujours bien même avant de partir
dans un tournoi comme ça deux doigts
d'avoir l'impression d'être en forme en
fait ben clairement et même même si la
coupe du monde et un million de fois
plus importante tu as quand même envie
de gagner le match pour pour être sûr de
ta force au sein du coup que j'aurais
fait ça vient clouer le comme ça ça fait
deux lots selon fait même 4 au final
s'il réussit à prendre
by vos mac il faut qu'il mette le fou en
d2 quoi tu penses c'est ce qui va fermer
mais même s'il mille fois en d2 après
avec son cavalier et prend 1,4 menace le
fou et ça à paros à peu refaire encore
un îlot away il prend comme ça mais
parce que c'est le symbole donc il
rajoute de la mairie
je pense que guillon je crois que j'en
joue lui aussi à la coupe du monde je
suis pas sûr et je crois qu'il joue lui
aussi la coupe du monde seul top combien
la coupe du monde il ya des
qualifications c'est par continent etc
mais il ya 128 joueurs en tout seul dans
le top 100 douze ans après comme tu as
des places sur sur des continents il ya
peu de joueurs du top 100 ça enlève un
peu déplacés puis à des qualifications
par des tours à mes suis quasiment sûr
qu'il joue je pense qu'on va nous dire
dans le dans le chat tout serait marrant
qui se rencontrent en vrai après vue qui
leur tombent les uns contre les autres
vu comment vous gérez xiong aujourd'hui
et vu son niveau de jeu d'un point de
vue général c'est sûr que maxime le
rencontrera un jour outre en tournois
parce que le mec il a que 16 enfin c'est
hallucinant entre 11h et que ceux
souvent de petite prodige à ces jeunes
un way point bas dès midi et enfin c'est
juste que les gens du chat qu'elle se
rende compte et gentil suivre le match
qu'on est en train de suivre un mec qui
est un peu inconnu entre guillemets du
grand public aujourd'hui mais qui
peut-être on en reparlera dans trois
quatre ans comme étant un joueur du top
20 mondial c'est tout à fait possible
bon là je la ressens que maxime la
piéger dans l'ouverture il a quand même
gagné un pion et ça fait quelques
minutes que jong réfléchi maxime un pion
+6 menace pour le monde prononcé trois
prises prises et de faire une fourchette
un roi tour leur fameuse voie là
j'imagine qu'ils peuvent juste faire f 6
cavaliers prend prise est bonne mais
n'osent plus bonjour amis le plomb
devait avoir une raison il a joué très
vite mais là il peut faire voir cette
manne en france et 3 et f6 voilà
classique il ya des îlots de pions
supplémentaire pour les blancs il ya un
pion plus pour les noirs va faire du fou
aux six cavaliers 17 tours c'est 8 on va
venir s'en prendre aux pions c'est bon
faut juste faire un petit peu attention
aux menaces aux menaces de l'adversaire
mais normalement ça devrait aller 11h à
tunis eric guillon gay génial pour son
âge il faut arrêter de se voiler la face
maxime joue mal par rapport à d'habitude
c'est vrai qu'ils jouent moins bien tout
à fait d'accord avec toi mais quand même
il faut souligner que que son adversaire
prend fin il prend toutes ses chances et
qu'il n'a que 16 ans fins et c'est
vraiment impressionnant
près c'est là qu'il monte sur une
certain que c'est pas fabien qui joue
avec les contrôles toujours fabien jeu
ça voilà il veut prendre le pion à une
pile une pièce de plus qui menace mais
bon je pense que diongue la juste donné
un son pur là il me la suis là n'ont pas
pu peut-être juste le pouce et ça finit
là il ya trois îlots moi je sais pas
comment ils pourraient remonter
non non c'est bon pour nous là il a pris
ce point là il va couvrir avec le flou
j'imagine et puis après il valait
peut-être chercher le cavalier qui a
plus trop de cases et à fabien qui est
dans le tchad justement tu vois qu'on le
troll je demande si on peut pas faire
tourbe et 5 et ours et 5 pour aller
choper le cas râle parce que lecavalier
tu vois il peut pas venir en b3 parce
que le pion sait il est cloué donc quand
tu fais tout pour défendre on va faire
tour c5
on va menacer le cavalier le cavaly
pourra pas revenir parce qu'on va juste
le prendre
donc je pense
à moins que je calcule comme un pied
c'est ce qu'il fait on pour cela ouais
bon on a égalisé ça va on revient on
revient dans le match ça va le faire
pas d'inquiétude moi j'y crois
j'espère parce qu'on veut vraiment le
voir en quart de finale contre gries
tchouk bon c'est une italienne une
nouvelle fois c'est la même couverture
que tout à l'heure tu te rappelles quand
le cavalier était venu en a cinq pour
menacer le fou ouais parce que voilà
faire d'ailleurs c'est parti pour en
tout cas pour le moment donc là souvent
l'idée des blancs c2c d'après ces jouets
des quatre pour prendre le centre c'est
pour ça qu'il a mis un pion des trois
ans et 3 et puis veut essayer de jouer
ces quatre voix ils sont entrés dans une
autre variante où les noirs sont venus
jouer rapidement des cinq pour contre
attaquer le centre donc ça bien à
retenir un pur tu es parti alexis quand
tu quand tu joues le centre très
important non mais attendez pas en mains
de que je peux mettre les pieds dans le
centre c'est ce que je fais est
important qu on veut que tu montes 1 on
veut que tu montes
résultat c'est moi qui vais faire les
blogs c'est toi qui va faire les vagues
d'heure ce serait peut-être un truc à
faire en parler avec avec dany mais on
pourrait essayer peut-être de de faire
peut-être avec toi des vidéos justement
objectif 1200 et puis petit à petit
j'avais peut-être envoyé à un yann
youtuber qui a fait sa hache un youtube
heures américains g à lui et vous êtes
sûr en ligne bah oui non mais ils jouent
en ligne moi je te parle de championnat
physique
non ça j'ai compris mes géré par là
qu'il ya un youtube heures comme ça
qu'ils américain qui a fait un tas de
live avec rennes avec des youtuber
d'échec et tout ça est petit à petit qui
est monté je crois qu'il est monté
jusqu'à 1450 mais que là ils plafonnent
un peu je t'enverrai c'est très marrant
alors dame eu deux jeux mètres la tour
en lin
il réfléchit il réfléchit mieux qu'ils
perdent qui tombe
pourquoi tant de haine
si on peut pas faire un truc un plan
bizarre j'aurais un cadre des quatre et
damas deux c'est moi qui suis
complètement fou on va perdre le pion c3
au passage mais bon c'est mes idées
complètement loufoque hors cac valeo 5
pour après tout quel plus aux beaudottes
ça aurait pu être un coup d'ailleurs
cavalli c5 ça aurait pu c'était un bon
candidat à la cavaille c5 d'autant plus
la menace la reine enfin la dame non
c'est parce qu'il fait bon il veut
vraiment jouer au sens tu vois il a
vraiment ramener un maximum de pièces
pour contrôler le centre et le combat il
se retrouve vraiment tu vois sur sur
cette petite partie d'échiquier la ja
roi a ensuite il est parti avec le roi
de la diagonale pour plus être embêté
c'est des gens qui donnent des idées
pour le don de la chaîne secondaire dans
l'autre choc
on s'oriente pop absolue bhl pour ta
chaîne sont d'accord 1° j'avais posé la
question pour peut être nommé mâchonne
vu que je ne faisais pas que du gaming
fait que cai c5 c'était une pièce
gratuite mais pas tout à l'heure parce
qu'il y avait le fou en e3 qui
protégeait un peu plus tôt ou alors
c'est moi qui hallucine et non le
fouetter bien que trois alors là il ya
un petit problème tu vois c'est qui
menacent notre fou et que normalement on
aimerait bien reculer le fou mais que
s'ils ont reculé le fou il y avait foule
prend des trois donc c'est pour ça qu'il
a joué des quatre maintenant ils
protègent avec la dame mais
ah ça fait trois îlots la peinture isolé
au centre en plus on n'a plus la paire
de fou et pas forcément très bien mais
pas forcément faire mais je suis
vraiment étonné enfin il joue vraiment
bien l'américain on maxime pas au top de
sa forme et l'américain vraiment solide
jeu parce qu'on pense fabien tu passes
il regarde depuis longtemps
bref si ça lui permet de de contrer la
diagonale du fou et éventuellement de
ramener son frangin 8 pour venir
attaquer une deuxième diagonale vers
angers limite il va revenir en d5
éventuellement il peut revenir en d5 en
tout cas peut-être mettre le cavaly vers
des cinq ans plusieurs options mais
elles ne vont pas bien ah sinon il se
met ça donne colonna n'ont pourtant
j'aurais bien vu la dame sur la colonne
j'ai pour consulter m son cavalier sur f
mais qu'ils attaquent le pion en g7 a
tué hier est comme ça mais il se fait
bien vissé parce que la dame elle
protège g7 et le fou tu vois il se fait
éteindre parce qu'il est bloqué derrière
le pion puis il a réussi à complètement
bloquée alors fabien il nous dit je
regarde pas depuis longtemps mais assez
impressionnant dion vu le score je
m'attendais à un massacre mais je reste
confiant pour le bullet fabien aussi
étonné un petit prodige à ba2 ce qui
fait ce qui va mettre le cavaliere en
9,5 après comme tu dis le plomb est
protégé par sa d'hommes noirs donc pour
le moment et puis on peut pas avoir le
fouet sur vous est bloqué plus on a un
pion de moi décidément le pion deux mois
il sera toujours là tu vois on va de les
réussir à le récupérer cela bon on
rentre dans une finale et ont réussi à
jouer des cinq ça c'est un soulagement
parce que mettre le pion ici regarde le
cavalier il fait la gueule parce que les
cas sont contrôlés en tout cas pour le
moment à court terme et notre fou il va
être heureux parce qu'il va pouvoir
enfin attaquer quelque chose donc là
peut-être que maxime est en train de est
en train de s'en sortir de sel
tout cas j'espère il peut prendre le
truc mais voilà il a récupéré son pion
taper un deuxième bah ouais en plus
c'est bizarre qu'il les bouger parce que
le protégé justement qui va venir
prendre des cinq à un moment donné il va
jouer sur l'idée que sur cavaliers prend
il ya cavaliers prend cavaliers prend et
le mc du couloir sata du temps prendre
plusieurs j'imagine déjà way monde
il met la tournée vers le pion il va
vouloir pousser on va ramener le roi on
va pousser le pion la maximin avec son
pion de plus il peut la gagner
franchement ça ferait du bien de
repasser à +1 ça ferait du bien déjà
plus d'un an
non là on à égalité à l'autoroute poteau
de coin je veux dire par là + 1 dans le
match on est à + 1 dans le sur la partie
oui on est un pion plus ou qui veut dire
dans le match ça ferait du bien de
repasser à +1 en plus violent
mais pourquoi pourquoi ils n'avancent
pas champions le club du protoss
de toute manière ce qui se dit qu'il a
le temps qu'ils veulent avancer
maintenant mais qu'on peut aussi
l'avancé plus tard se dire d'avoir le
temps alors qu'il ya une seconde c'est
comique et le bouge toujours pas
maintenant il se permet d'attendre 0
millisecondes
elle veut prendre le pion là pour le
coup là le pion
on pousse un autre parce qu'il devient
porte 7 mètres la tour ici un moment
donné je sais pas ce qu'il fait à il
défend comme ça surtout reprend y'avait
cavaliers des cinq échecs et on aurait
regagné la tour grâce à une découverte
c'est la tour prend le pion une bonne
fourchette 1 en wallon et de l'oeuf ou
la découverte il ya la tour qui prend la
tour après away je peux bon ça va ça va
ça va il a deux pions plus et il a
réussi à stabiliser
il va mettre un petit échec avec tours 4
il va commencer à envoyer les pions
n'empêche qu'il a peu joué la facilité
j'ai l'impression un ouais il ya un peu
de ça il ya aussi l'autre qui défend
bien et un peu les deux mais là non avec
les deux pions plus ça devrait aller
il ya là bas pourquoi il a pris la
fourchette est évidente la wii il avait
très peu de temps un
et puis il était mal quand et sous
pression comme ça ou d'un moment ça ça
finit par craquer et à une fourchette un
truc qui arrive
bon on est passé devant sais pas combien
de temps il reste les gens peuvent nous
dire éventuellement combien de temps il
nous reste il devrait avoir au dessus de
nous le petit chrono on retourne avec cc
on a vu sa toute première partie une
benoni avec ce fou qui qui rayonne on
dit qu'il reste vingt minutes encore et
après on va passer aux bulles est ce
serait bien d'arriver au budget avec un
petit avantage
et dans cette structure de pions souvent
le problème cession des 6 parce que tu
vois il peut pas être soutenus par
d'autres pions à part la donne ouais
t'es obligé d'avoir des pièces pour le
défendre
donc tu t'en sors mes ou alors tu
m'aides cavaliers en 5 mai pour couvrir
du protégé par le pion et par la tour
saint qui vont échanger prison passe en
10 ans passant ou pas ouais mais comme
je compte des 900 tu vois et que je fais
j'avance un plan de deux cases pour
éviter de me confronter à un autre pion
donc le mec peut faire la prise en
passant tu vois et bat à chaque fois
c'est à son avantage de faire une prise
en passant mais j'ai l'impression qu'ils
sont pas au courant qu'on peut faire ça
c'est parce que parce que 90% du temps
le mec ne fait pas la prison pas sentir
il n'a juste pas savoir ouais donc moi à
chaque fois que le temps tu vois je
bluffe un peu et ce qui va la faire ou
pas s'il l'a fait c'est fou de vie pour
moi et 90% du temps il la fait pas donc
je me dis le mec l'époque on peut la
faire en fait
marrant quand même parce que 909 santa
des mecs qui jouent quand même un peu
aux échecs déjà
bah écoute en tout cas ça me faisant un
nom mais ce serait possible il doit
jouer comme ça sur internet et ils n'ont
pas dû forcément se renseigner sur
toutes les règles ils doivent pas
connaître et c'est tant mieux pour toi
après 16 en main je joue au bluff est en
profite pas raison quelque part tu joues
sur tes connaissances quoi par exemple
fois jeté linverse tu vois c'est moi qui
fais la prise en passons et les mecs
chaussures et c'était beaucoup qu'on
pouvait la faire ils n'avaient pas prévu
tout ça quoi ait fana idéal un pion
ouais 900 c'est le coup du berger pas
plus moi non pas comme non ça passe pas
du tout non à ton niveau le coup du
berger déjà non non je n'essaye même pas
le coup du berger
non en fait en fait 900 / tu as points
comme c'est plus fort que 900 en réalité
en réalité en fait les mecs sur internet
avec les petites îles et des petits lots
ils sont plus forts que que s'il est
avide équivalent avec un héros réels
mais oui à 1 900 encore des buts en plus
soin et et entêté je pense que sam hill
que tu commences à rentrer dans le toit
que tu passes de débutants plus ça je
sais pas comment on pourrait dire mais
tu sors de cette catégorie là en fait
cavalier bay de las c'est une menace
mais pour le moment c'est pas encore à
nous de jouer d'ailleurs on pourrait
même venir en c3 parce que tu ailles à
ce fou qui rayonne de la whey ah ouais
ouais donc il ya pas mal de cases encore
possible
moi j'aurais bien vu cavaliers b2 tu
vois puis après ah ben non manouche sud
est c'est ce que je voulais faire mais
en fait ils bougent et sa dame puis
après voilà me prenais le fou frei
prenez le cas venir une belle fourchette
à faire sinon ils envoient le pion cc4
c3 ça va avancer il y aura le plus rien
quatre ans prises
ouais je pense que ça peut le faire
cette partie j'ai l'impression que ça
avance bien du côté de maxime et ils
menacent maintenant ton idée peut-être
d'ailleurs un qui peuvent avoir
peut-être arrivé avec le cavalier b3 qui
sera éventuellement protégé par le
purement pour le moment il ya encore un
courage j'aime bien le foot il en ce 3
tu veux mettre le fou en c3 le gardien
c'est dans le fond cette robe comme ça
après tumulte chavalier menos la la la
la dame elle il va juste bouger et des
pièces elles ont été un peu attachées
les unes aux autres
vraiment je voyais tu vois que cavalli
en c3 il le prend avec la tour ah bah
non non il va changer une tour carrée
bon mais là on est pas mal avec les noms
on a quand même ce pion qui est fort le
cas les caries finalement b2 mais là il
va faire un dogme c'est de gagner le
pion des 5
non je fais pas d'hommes se montre
messieurs dames ces deux ça changeait
pas grand-chose hélas en plus le
cavalier il empêche autour de venir sur
la colonne des pour attaquer la dame
bon c'est bien ça maintenant qu'elle est
des trois ans menace la tour est en
quête pour un f4 échec on va refaire une
fourchette
le sacré film tour oui mais pour pour
venir avec le cavalier en d3 et pour
venir prendre un f4 sur échec
je pense en tout cas bonne soupe bonne
fourchette ça ou prem's et après il
reprend avec un week-end à tours mais je
pense que faire un échec et puis à
prévenir de mettre la dame en f5 et puis
menacé menacé des maths en fait avoir je
pense que l'on va faire dame f5 comme ça
ils gardent la menace sur la dame ou
d'un match 5
on y apprend paso-doble vrai mais comme
ça il a enlevé sa dame de la menace ils
menacent de prendre h3 et de fermes à
tanger de après du coup il abandonne son
pion quoi ouais mais bon là qu'est ce
qui peut faire si fait d'un met fin pour
protéger ont fait d'artprice trois ans
gagne le cavalier et si fait qu'un
malaisien pour protéger le pion prend la
dame avec le cavalier donc dans les deux
cas il a gagné parce qu'il ya une du
matériel après font encore finir la
partie mais ils avancent de plus en plus
jean surette la dame ans 6-8 il
réfléchit prend plus son temps il veut
peut-être laissé tourner la montre pour
arriver au but l'aide plus rapidement
les débats sont davantage si mais bon -
ja partie cieszyn alive a gagné la
partie mais peut-être qu'il veut il veut
utiliser du temps pour déjà pour être
sûr qu'ils gagnent mais il se dit
peut-être aussi que laisser tourner la
montre ce n'est pas une mauvaise chose
auquel je sais tout reprend okello de
faire un truc marrant c'est que si tu
prends saddam il veut faire un échec
perpétuelle ça marche pas du tout en
fait il aurait fait échec incessamment
avec les deux tours avec les la tour en
fait il aurait suivi le roi si tu
faisais dame programme il aurait on me
l'a home le feu ça souvent pour ça que
maxime a fait un peu attention mais bon
allez plus de plus de ça ça fait du bien
enfin on reprend un peu nos distances
on prend un peu de distance il peut
mettre le fou en f4 et ensuite son
cavalier en b5 et aux menaces
le c7 attend un long chemin à faire
parce qu'il faut encore que tu des
cavaliers que tu perds pas le pion des
quatre ça malheureusement ça marche à
ton niveau encore ça peut marcher encore
jusqu'à près de 1000 1100 peut-être même
1200 des menaces comme ça mais après
c'est sais c'est que dans des positions
spécifique que tu peux le faire parce
que les joueurs ils vont naturellement
le se défendre en fait
bon belle ouverture pour la reine toute
la colonne pour elle mais bon à terme il
ya une tour qui va venir se mettre en
face et qu'il attaquera pourra pas
rester là pendant pendant très longtemps
parole qui nous lie je sens que ça va
être une tuerie ambühl est très possible
parce que maxime eu l'impression que là
depuis qu'il a été mené d'un point en
fait ça a vraiment réveillé fini les
conneries pions en b 4 sur pied en mai 4
est un piège classique on va revenir
c'est qu'ils te fais fou prend des
quatre et ils jouent sur le clouage de
ta tour ah ouais donc le seul chèque
après coup c'est un peu pour ça que j'en
profite pour te le montrer parce que ça
peut arriver dans tes parties bon la
cloche comme ça moi j'y pense pas en
fait j'ai remarqué que tu pensais pas
trop clouage des pions en fait je me
fais avoir toujours sur les clauses
chemin faut que tu t'entraînes faut que
tu utilises ton l'abonnement diamant
tu fais des fois les petits
entraînements tactiques ou pas ou pas du
tout autrement en ce moment donc le plus
de parts alors là on a ce qu'on appelle
les rocks opposé c'est à dire que tu as
un joueur qui a rock et allait l'allèle
dames et l'autre car calais le roi et
idées souvent c'est juste de balancer
les pions comme un gros barbares en fait
parce que tu t'en fiches un peu de
perdre des pions enfin tu t'en fiches
pas complètement mais si tu veux ça va
ouvrir les lignes pour pour faire
dévaler la tour en fait donc pour ça que
tu envoies très rapidement tes pion à
l'assaut du roi adverse
et là c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
bourrin tu vas même les noirs ils
donnent un pion aussi parce qu'ils
veulent ouvrir les colonnes autour du
roi pour pour venir attaquer avec les
tours avec la dame avec two way ça celui
qui sera le plus besoin quoi oui la fois
debout roll la fois de violents pour mes
chances que maxime est bien là
bon si j'aime bien les rocks opposé mais
je pense que je pense qu'il peut lui
faire mal mais il peut éventuellement
menacer peut-être de mètres carrés
angers 5 pour venir prendre f7 comme
thème bien le faire ça peut être une
menace si le djia reprend son caramel
sera bien au centre des absents que les
pièces blanches sont simplement mieux
placé l'emprise prise mais je pense h5
on y va pour un aller se faire flouer f5
l'autre donc fou ces trois bien joué ils
attaquent le pion aux cinq en premier et
peut-être à privas faire j'ai quatre
pour empêcher fouet f5 et après h5 il va
venir bourriner à fond le roi de verser
alors qu'on a more goût sur le chat
c'est un des indes et modérateur de la
chaîne ça fait longtemps que j'avais pas
vu sur sur un live donc bonjour à lui
seul une mort douce
non tu vois il fait le fameux gkd dont
je te parlais pour empêcher fois f5 il
veut y aller à la bourre en h5 donc
j'aurai mes jeux 5 - g5 en fait il va
mettre le fou en gsm et tu vas pas
vraiment l'ouvrir alors peut-être
maintenant à près d'1 me 7 c'est un peu
différent mais je pense h5 quand même en
fait je pense h5 quand même tu as dû me
venir décapsuler et en plus tu as le
pion là qui est cloué comme ça tu en as
rafion prend pions prend et dame prend
qui jouera sur le clouage ah tiens fsgt
quoi mais bon avec adam riess est ça
change un peu peut-être qu'il veut c'est
ce qu'il veut y aller à la dure vraiment
route unique les stream c'est son métier
aussi au war regarde mais autant il
donne sa noble mais regarde sur dame
prend il voulait faire tout reprend et
sur x fuite
ils voulaient pro à temps j'ai raté un
épisode sur wii fit je me demande ce qui
se passait en fait
surtout reprend et fuit thiaroye g7 et
surtout prend la fuite qu'elle apprend
ces quatre échecs on fait quoi là du
coup je sais pas mais j'aimerais bien
voir la vidéo chat peut-être que
réclament ces quatre bras bien je fais
quoi là du cool je pense que je suis pas
non plus mais on est dans cette position
maintenant et mon suroît bien les gens
il y avait foule f5 et chats qui répond
juste au chat au passage et tout reprend
dès 8 h au profit du tourcoing fc à tout
est exact bon je pose non plus elle
prend un pion essaie de pousser les
pions sur la colonne des chaussures à
yahvé tourcoing fc est exact exact exact
bon mais l'adoption plus pour maxime
bon c'est gagner ou king
bon on est bien là il a trois points de
plus à nice et papeete juste pour
montrer aux gens
ouais c'est pas parfait tous et après tu
fais tu fais tout réfuté fait qui est
tour à tour g8 matt white trois points
de plus
comme quoi moyen de temps plus seul
avantage d'au maximum 10 rue
généralement ça al'avantage de joueurs
les plus forts et de réduire le plus tu
réduis normalement plus les meilleurs
font parler la puissance de calcul et la
vitesse tiens c'est une position qu'on
avait déjà vu on avait vu cavaliers
prendre des six fou prend des six dames
prend des six c'est dans une des toutes
premières parties ouais
non mais maxime c'est sûr que c'est sûr
qu'il a un peu enfin voilà dès qu'il a
été mené au score ça lui a permis de
vraiment se motiver et d'y aller
j'aurais mille cavaliers en en 5,2
secondes
là on a eu un problème si ces prisons
des six soit exactement timo rue tout à
l'heure au sinon il mettait ça ça donne
en 2 6 2 je pense qu'il n'a pas fait à
cause de cavaliers costumés acef de
aussi ça aurait été intéressant aussi
en fait on demande ce qui à la
différence entre un 2007 et en 2008 mais
en fait un peu tout les 2008 qui calcule
mieux ils sont plus forts dans certains
compartiments du jeu suivant lesquelles
et ils sont plus forts en ouverture ils
sont juste plus fort un peu partout
voilà il a perdu un pion un battement na
waie mais il va récupérer le pion b2
derrière ouais ouais ouais non mais là
ça va aller je m'inquiète beaucoup moins
la soirée prévu que la tourbe comme ça
ça te permet de prendre le pion à 2,5
apprend avec le cavalier pour les pour
les blancs peut-être le roi en c1
on a trois ou en b3 je sais pas
exactement où va le roi mais dans cet
esprit là tiens la regarde l'idée c'est
que si prenez le le fou en un an à 3 les
karellis et cat échec fourchette en 9e
jeu de vue cela tu es jolie away me
fourchette ce toujours joueuse surtout
avec les cavaliers n'ont les fourches
aden les pions quoi c'est moins
esthétique
ah bah quand tu te crois une fourche à
taille qu'un pion tard compte pour que
je les peuples alors la prochaine partie
ce sera de 1960 et après il y aura le
jura les bullet seul je me fais toujours
à le voir c'est le fourchette avec le
fou qui menacent les deux tours avec un
fou qui masse de tours c'est rare ça
premier temps on va le savoir vous comme
récemment ça me le fait c'est souvent
alors est-ce qu'il va continuer par
cavalier b2 échec
oui ce qui va trouver mieux ce cas et b2
et chaque jour on joue de nouveau sur un
clouage n'ont pas trouvé mieux si tu as
juste faire cavalier c4 et répéter les
coups une nouvelle fois ou peut-être
qu'il va faire quelque chose comme fou
des quatre échecs est rentré dans une
variante plus compliqué pourtant
continué à jouer sur les clous âge
peut-être peut-être pas qu'en tout cas
il a plusieurs lots l'un comme mam il a
un peu moins pour le moment même si
l'activité jusqu'à 6 je pense qu'il veut
préparer foulée quatre échecs et pas
laisser le roi partir trop loin
donc a valu un pas mal il protège le
cavalier et il protège le pion ces deux
toi d'ailleurs qui est extérieur au jeu
d'échecs
qu'est ce que tu penses du fait que les
hommes et les femmes soient séparés pour
les tournois d'échecs parce que nous
parlons avec fabien trouve que c'est un
peu étrange maintenant aujourd'hui
bah moi je trouve ça normal tu vois pour
à un sport telles que le foot ou le truc
comme ça ou c'est le corps le plus
important tu vois c'est vrai que pour
les échecs quand je vous dis rien qui
nous différencie comme femme quoi c'est
juste l'intellect l'intellect
ckac sports c'est la condition physique
à la rigueur hockey parce que nous on a
un plus de muscles mais sinon j'ai eu
des échecs quoi c'est bizarre c'est un
argument de faille un gîte à fait
d'accord avec lui c'est comme si on
faisait un bac et un baccalauréat garçon
un baccalauréat fille influence très
très étrange quand même c'est comme un
sous entendu comme cole les finisseurs
et moins intelligentes
non mais c'est vraiment le cas c'est sa
famille qui dit bien joué absolue 100%
d'accord non mais c'est vrai enfin c'est
lui que tous les fans tous les gens qui
ne réfléchissent un peu logiquement j'ai
l'impression qu'ils pensent comme ça
face à me paraît juste tellement logique
aussi mais c'était intéressant de voir
ton opinion en fait en tant qu' en tant
que nos joueurs quoi bein c'est bizarre
que les échecs féminin existe encore en
fait tourtereaux ce moment avec toutes
les révolutions entre guillemets où on
essaye vraiment dos enfin que la femme
ait une place au égale à l'homme c'est
bizarre que ça existe encore en 2017
mais là ça m'a vraiment les joueurs
d'échecs en plus serait qui est d'autant
plus bizarre il y en a certains qui ont
une réputation aussi apparemment
un peu macho ce qui paraît si quoi sauf
peut-être enfin bon moi je sais des
rumeurs on marque on m'a dit que les
joueurs de chaque certains étaient
beaucoup moins chaud dans le monde des
échecs mais sur youtube aussi au bas où
il met ensuite à des modes chaud partout
ans à spine de voter on va espérer que
maxime se soient pas trompés parce que
là il a pas mal de pièces attaqué de
partout voilà il peut prendre son pied
en un an
voilà il peut plus pourquoi il prend pas
son poulain je m'en veux parce qu'il y
avait une enfilade ont peu importe son
nouveau chemin budget post the way c'est
allé très vite
bon sympa ça pas nouvelle une nouvelle
partie non perdu en tout cas de maxime
c'est sûr je pense ça doit être gagnant
cette histoire et c'est jamais évident
les finales deux tours même si un pion
de plus surtout qu'il est hyper loin le
pion qui peut facilement arriver
jusqu'au jusqu'au fond la ramasse
d'arion c'est la personne qui est dans
tag l'île de ré ouais il dit c'est comme
dans tout il ya toujours une séparation
hommes femmes c'est comme les écoles
pour les filles et les garçons qui
avaient en 1950
maintenant ça n'existe plus parce que
c'est débile ça fasse sa part et régis
bizarre en fait un appareil juste
bizarre tu imagines si l'ipl pubis était
encore séparé au poker il n'y a pas de
séparation mais voilà enfin je veux dire
pour des trucs ou celle un tacle
l'intellect avant je vois pas l'utilité
de faire comme fille quoi ou alors ça
sous-entend que voilà les défis sont
plus intelligentes sont moins
intelligentes ou plus intelligente
serait marrant en fait on ne l'aimé pas
contre les hommes parce qu'on a parlé de
ses maîtresses se [ __ ] une raclée mais
en plus ça peut être un peu de ça enfin
je sais pas quand ça a été créé les
échecs avec les minimes se sont dit il
faut faire gaffe quand même si on l'aimé
avec nous cette scène nous battre on va
créer une catégorie voit la manière une
femme dans le dans le top 100 la moment
une ou deux à wenn com
c'est peu mais en fait il ya une grosse
question sur le fait est ce que c'est
parce que elles sont séparées du coup il
ya moins d'émulation aussi bon alors le
fait qu'ils aient pas cette femme dans
le top-100 fait que les femmes ne
s'intéressent pas vous cause de choc
possible c'est vraiment difficile de
prime abord plein d'explications il ya
plein de gens qui ont essayé de donner
des explications c'est un sujet très
épineux
mais bon en tout cas on pourrait au
moins essayer de les faire jouer avec
les hommes et puis voir si elles si
elles obtiennent un niveau similaire
c'est tout à fait possible
bon les échecs 960 on a quatre points
d'avance donc on va peut-être réussir à
faire même mieux que le plus suite que
j'annonce en début de match au final au
stress pour rien là on a stressé on
s'est mis un peu sous pression
ammann dario apparemment ils jouent aux
échecs en la personne de tags il sait
qu'il a initié sa copine aux échecs
ouais peut-être je savais pas j'ai fait
quelques parties et compte quelques
quelques-uns de mes officiers celle où
va mal rien que c'était facile quoi
olaya un bon truc là cavalier cavalier e
5 qui arrive sur ensuite offset et ça se
peut qu'ils le jouent très bien que
l'empêcher non mais ça va ça va mais on
est tranquille et là tu aux échecs 960
ce qu'il en sait qu'on peut faire le
petit rock en se marrant avec leurs
engins avec la tour en f1 ça c'est hyper
fun je trouve vos échecs 960 d'avoir le
roi qui se barre de l'autre côté de
l'échiquier mais je pense qu'à faire
j'ai quatre j'allais dire fou j'ai trois
cavaliers des 5 et qui va se faire un
truc avec le cai qui a pu me rend ses
sets je sais pas je pense que ça va être
un massacre cette partie mais qu'arrive
à me ranger cette japd être sûr qu'ils
allaient prendre des cinq direct où je
la sens très bien cette partie
ouais moi j'aurais fait qu'ils avaient
deux des cinq quoi qu'on fasse il avoir
surtout que j'apporte le feu cette quoi
ouais tu y es tu vas venir prendre ici
aussi c'est ce qui fait est là il va
mettre le fond en g3 il va commencer à
attaquer par ici va attaquer de partout
je pense qu'il va encore la gagne et ça
la nati maureen dit peut pas encore
faire un gros rock parce que la tour en
d1 gêne c'est tout à fait vrai marrant
j'adore ces trucs de notre d'échec 967
des positions très inhabituel c'est très
marrant non là la dame vient combine
avec le cavaly pour menacer le pion e7
va faire du fou g3
aya fait petit rock finalement voilà je
peux faire dame h cette menace le fou
d'après le fou il peut aller nulle part
mais pour le moment il ya le cavalier
emprise tu peux le faire quand même
mais je vais faire un échange remarque
va de toute façon faire un échange
c'est dommage qu'il ait pas un fou blanc
parce que pas un sur quatre branches
aurait pu il aurait pu mener cette
baisse est prêt il peut pas tout avoir
il a déjà un avantage matériel mais ça
peut être un peu dangereux parce que tu
vois ce pion g4 là le fait qu'il ait
fait petit rock sont rois il est quand
même assez exposée ouais ouais bien de
faire cavalier aussi c'est comme ça la
tourelle enfermé aussi un ou ce cavalier
là et devenir un second une fée de
change
la tour en métal et il va réussir à la
sauver avec fu g6 ok pourquoi pas
c'est pas c'est pas si simple maintenant
la dame est attaqué et je n'aimais pas
du tout ce qu'on peut dire à qui s'est
mis sous pression avec le petit rock
ouais c'est pas mieux du bon côté
surtout que là après un beau nom parce
qu'il aurait pu prendre un même il veut
y gagner le cavalier en fait parce que
lecavalier est cloué est un bon gars ils
abandonnèrent et le kabyle été perdu
mais il s'est mal de portes qui donnent
leur nom il était bien il était petit
est vraiment pas mal et tout d'un coup
on fait un petit rock je sais pas
c'était assez soupçonnant comme coup
parce que le roi il s'est retrouvé très
mal placé alors qu'il avait le temps de
faire autre chose non il a du mal en 960
il a du mal
bon on a trois points d'avancé avant la
section bull est donc il est temps les
gens de allez on partage un maximum sur
facebook de partout on récupère le poste
de l'aps hall et sur twitter et fabien
qui va partager de partout fabien et on
le sait pas mais ils partagent tout le
temps fidèle au poste tant fidèle au
poste pascal vaucluse il fallait faire
tour f1 et gants et et grand roque est
probablement il valait mieux mettre la
tour en f1
on était pas mal de gens en espagne que
dans le tchad en fait tous les gens sont
plus ou moins d'accord avec nous après
ce que je comprends que la séparation
entre les femmes et les hommes et en
même temps qu'ils seraient pas d'accord
j'aimerais bien voir ses arguments gones
malgré le fait que tu aies que tout le
monde soit d'accord c'est un truc qui ne
change pas c'est assez marrant c'est
assez étrange
donc il va rester trente minutes moi je
vais aller chercher le le compteur temps
je vais mettre trente minutes comme ça
on va être prêt pour la fin je sais pas
combien de spectateurs est ce qu'on est
monté jusqu'à 500 ou pas
en et 423 un premier pas forcément
d'accord avec le les échecs féminin dont
il ya quand même des gens ne sont pas
forcément d'accord c'est un débat c'est
un débat 426 ado quand il pourrait que
ça y est ma force pas spécialement
d'accord et une pas non plus qu'il en
désaccord 400 centrales et on se bat on
partage c'est quand même c'est voilà
c'est la fin du premier tour
je retweete mon retweete pascal où ils
compensent les joueuses des chèques mais
les joueuses et chaque elles peuvent
aussi être partial parce que
financièrement elles profitent de ce
système là stoner basse que du coup il
ya des tournois féminin et des tournois
mixtes et dans les tons à féminin il ya
des prix et donc si on commence à faire
que des tournois mixtes les joueuses
elles n'auront plus de prix féminin en
fait spécialement pour les femmes
ouais donc sais pas si tu demandes aux
joueuses du haut niveau elles peuvent
être partial fois c'est comme si je
demande à absolu ce que tu penses qu'il
faut aref aux fatwas des pas que sur
youtube donc tu t'en fiches mais si on
demandait à un mec est que sur youtube
et qu'on lui disait qu'est ce que tu
penses si on interdisait les vidéos sur
internet
si une chaîne youtube apparemment les
vidéos sur internet mais bon tout un tas
de vidéos qui n'ont pas forcément à mon
avis lieu d'être sur youtube qui a
détruit quand même un peu space qui sont
à la mode des fois ça c'est clair
et donc c'était forcément partial si ça
se fait gagner de l'argent c'est
obligatoire
non c'est clair parce qu'après si y'a
que des tournois mixtes
c'est comme je dis on n'a que deux dans
le top 100 on va être compliqué pour
elle c'est en fait c'est les nouvelles
générations qui vont qui vont en
bénéficier parce que je pense qu'à force
en fait la différence ce gomery si tu
fais jouer les filles en ce sens avec
les garçons les plus jeunes âgés qui
n'est pas de séparation et tout ça je
pense que petit à petit en fait ça
équilibrerait mais il y avait j'avais un
petit peu ce sujet en fondant le dans le
film le tournoi où tu avais la fille qui
disait enfin à un moment il en parle un
petit peu de ça tu as un dialogue ou la
fille explique les filles sont sous
représentées dans le monde des échecs
qu'elle veut faire tout pour pour que le
l'entraîneur ils l'apprennent dans
l'équipe et tous ses doigts ça doit vous
parler vu que fab de bornes d'un
dialogue avance sur le sujet c'est pas
l'air si favre a influencé pour ce
dallas sur ce dialogue ou pas il
pourrait il pourrait nous dire
éventuellement mais tu as tout un
dialogue et toute une trame de fond là
dessus j'ai l'impression quand j'ai vu
le film mais c'est une question
intéressante en fait que presque la
fille tu vois elle est obligée de faire
des trucs sexuelle pour pour être dans
l'équipe tout tu vois aucun ça encourage
pas à enlever la séparation bas en soie
sans courage pas mais ça dénonce et tu
vois ouais enfin j'aurais l'impression
entre je sais pas ce que femme on pense
mais on est parti en tout cas pour les
bullet on a on a trois points d'avance
ils sont ils ont tout est changé la
donne de façon ça notre faire des nuls
c'est à notre avantage ici c'est notre
loterie king
bon l'autre il a des cavaliers un peu
dangereux mais je pense que c'est plutôt
du vent je pense pas qu'il puisse faire
grand chose avec ses cavaliers on les
gère bien pour le moment
le fou il est bien placé il contrôle des
bonnes cases ya depuis on a trois qui
peut être dans le viseur et les
cavaliers vont pas pouvoir rester aussi
proche
non ça devrait aller maintenant cavalier
se fait chasser
je vais devoir repartir cet affront
pourra bouger notre tour en huit pour le
ré attaquer ça devrait aller moscou 4
secondes 3 2 aux ied a été déconnecté sa
chaîne il est déconnecté il a été
déconnecté lui un problème de connexion
trop dommage quand on perd comme ça tant
mieux
les nouveaux joueurs ça nous fait plus 4
bon soit c'est comme le le miz clique
doivent tout à l'heure le mystique nous
avait coûté cher du coup ça équilibre
les échanges pour le moment on a perdu
pas mal depuis ont quand même on a perdu
deux pions dans la sphère germes sont
que des que maxime prend vraiment
l'avantagé ils se relâchent et ils
recommencent à ce besoin à ce laisser
aller
bon il va et je suis quasiment sûr qu'il
va finir par gagner le match mais c'est
laborieux
c'est ça il ya vraiment besoin des temps
d'être en difficulté dans ce match pour
pour se faire mal ou alors il est super
serein puis en fait il joue quoi tout
simplement qu'il veut je vais faire
comme dans le combat de mayweather
contre mcgregor en fait il le tien tu
vois bon mais ça se peut qu'ils
réussissent à alma t il ya des variantes
ma rangers 6 3 par an et fuite on peut
essayer de faire [ __ ] angers c'est 3
prend cavaliers prend g7 et / ou apprend
faire d'alger cinq matches pour être un
match assez joli alors voilà je le peux
donc ça se peut qu'ils réussissent quand
même à pêcher en eaux troubles
notre petit maxime nationale l'autre
français le plus proche de top classe et
combien il est 31e peut-être 32e etienne
bacrot il avait fait une émission télé
quand il était gamin d'ailleurs sur les
échecs tu pourras te renseigner si ça
intéresse oui tu appelles plus du nom
d'être dans le chat on va nous dire mais
il a animé une émission télé sur les
échecs c'est sympa d'ailleurs et là il
va récupérer le cavalier qui est cloué
up gagné n'était pas forcément bien
parti mais il a réussi à gagner durant
une minute quand même la différence de
niveau se fait encore plus ressentir
well as 5 pour d'avant cela non il a
pris la plus cinq et en plus il ya la
pendule qui tourne entre guillemets ya
de moins en moins deux parties à venir
donc là on est quand même très confiant
à s'appeler etienne et mat
exactement je pourrais essayer de
chercher je sais pas si tu veux trouver
quelque chose sur youtube les tiennes
matin je regarde un jour dans un coin de
la tête
ouais tu peux te trouves tu peux tu peux
trouver à l'appareil
non non tu vas aller prendre le curé que
deux tu fatigues là non je crois que la
dernière demi-heure pour toi c'est la
demi-heure de tron ont eux toujours ça
me fait toujours ça et le lendemain au
boulot ça se passe comment bâle a vu
qu'on va finir plutôt vu qu'on a
commencé une heure plus tôt peut-être
que ce sera mieux mais en général j'ai
du mal à dormir après c'est à décoller
en plus parce que c'est
c'est assez bizarre mais comment dire
c'est enfin jeu quand je ferme les yeux
j'ai des casses partout je vois des
positions partout trop bizarre alors que
c'est pas moi qui joue en plus ça tu
vois encore on pourrait dire parfois ça
me le fais tu vois quand j'achète des
parties des partis comme ça pendant des
heures et que je me couchais juste après
ça me le fait mais le la whey et ce même
s'ils ont progressé après les mac
quand on a commenté un match comme ça où
[Musique]
bah disons que j'apprends pas des
tactiques quoi j'apprends plus qu'il
faut pas faire certaines erreurs dans
les trucs chloé faut que je me mette en
tête qu'il faut bien faire gaffe à ce à
quoi
en fait c'est ça c'est qu'on parle
plutôt de principes généraux et même si
ça te fait un peu progressé je pense que
tu le vois pas directement nantes est
partie parce que ça joue souvent sur des
tactiques encore pour soi disant que ce
n'est pas en regardant la tactique de
maxime que je veux que je te refaire
obama prochaine partie quoi
mais bon on réussira à prendre quand
même des petites choses stratégie qui
ont réussi à prendre des petits concept
mais c'est pas des choses qui ces choses
qui sert mais qu'en fait tu sens pas
tout de suite en fait ça viendra avec le
temps voilà je pense que maxime nouvelle
fois gagné à quoique beaucoup pour hbo
son show là parce qu'en fait si prenez
le fou il y avait la dame emprise qu'il
n'avait pas le temps de prendre et la
loterie ci prend le fou l'idée c'est de
faire tout reprendre et deux échecs sade
et villeroy et il va prendre la dame au
prochain ah ouais c'est pour ça qu'il
n'a pas appris le fou est la maxime il a
pris le pion alors il laisse sa adam key
users
mais il doit y avoir un truc oui bah y
avait simplement reprendre la dame de
l'adversaire angers cas puisqu'elle
était en prise et maintenant il va
prendre le four b2 il va reprendre et il
va se retrouver avec pas mal de plus il
a trois points de plus donc ça devrait
tranquillement se passer pour maxime une
nouvelle fois là qui envoie ses pions et
il va faire 3 2 c'est fini il va mettre
laurent g7 il va prendre en f 7 il
envoyait le pion à deux lots de 20
mètres la tour devant et il va lui
envoyer le pion h et en fait il se fait
tirer des deux côtés tu peux pas
défendre les deux pions tu vois il va il
allait lui envoyer le pion à et puis
après quand la tour s'en va et lui
envoyer le 2e alors on en est à combien
on en a plus 6 atteignant voit le curage
direct line s'est mise en mode troll la
salle et distille le troll est hélas
combien de temps
on peut demander dans le chat il doit
rester une vingtaine de minutes
j'imagine donc il a fait ça fait 7 hui
partie si le mène à +8 c'est fini quoi
ouais mais là je pense que je pense que
c'est bon je pense qu'on le tient je
pense qu'on verra une demi finale un
quart de finale contre rich ou qu allah
il peut prendre le pion en sucette
ouais pour allez le prendre je sais pas
s'il va le faire il pourrait peut-être
peur de se faire enfermer la dame comme
dans la partie tout à l'heure as écrit
time is up alors ça vous auriez dû me le
dire ah là là on n'a pas le temps bon
ben c'est pas combien de temps on va
mettre 18 minutes et coûte
on va le mettre un peu au hasard et on
va voir ce qui se passe
il a pas pris le pion un nom il n'est
pas allé prendre le pion finalement
alors là il ya une idée quand même qui
va te plaire c'est que sur quel droit
prend f2 je vais te le montrer
il y avait cavaliers jca-t cheikh sympa
ah ouais c'était joli ou là là j'ai
l'impression que cette partie là est
difficile pour maxime est bon on sent
qu'il n'est pas très sérieux
wells rush 20 ouais ça a été un peu ça
tout le match au final dès qu'il a dès
qu'il a plus vraiment besoin
alors ils disent 19 min sur le stream
anglophone ça veut dire qu'on a une
ligne de plus merci à timo rue donc on
va remettre
on va remettre 18 maintenant en fait je
pense le temps qu'ils les 10 et machin
alors qu'est ce qu'on a on a réussi à
récupérer une qualité pendant que
changer le temps mais c'est pas facile
parce que les noirs en un gros hamas
beaucoup de pièces au centre mais bon il
ya peu de temps comme ça tu sèmes à ce
niveau là ils peuvent faire des grosses
gaffes
j'ai changé tour
je veux pas changer on dirait regard des
pièces mais as-tu à ses cavaliers ils
sont pénibles parce qu'ils peuvent faire
des fourchettes avec les tours blanches
il ya beaucoup de pièces noire qui
s'approche de plus en plus le bon maxime
joue très vite et assez bien parce que
tu as il est en défense et c'est plus
difficile de défendre que d'attaquer
quand à peu de temps depuis ici
d'attaquer que de défendre pardon mais
quand tu défends alors que tu as 2 qui a
valu en face qui peuvent te faire des
fourchettes 7e bouge pas comme il faut
qu'on n'a pas pris son cavalier parce
que sinon le pion aux riffs hill et adam
ouais ouais bon + 5
non mais là maxime où ils jouent pour se
marrer ils envoient le pion à trop
grande avance il rigole
il n'ya trop d' avance alors qu'est-ce
qui se passerait s'il prend le plonge
les demandes et elle s'en fiche il donne
des pions en un coup
il était pas venue était pas bien avec
les plus grandes convictions du monde à
ce père qui jouera mieux qu'en hongrie
tour parce que sinon il va faire
massacrer mais bon j'imagine que tu
imagines si ça se retourne contre lui et
puis que au final de son adversaire et
gagnent partie sur partie c'est un peu
dangereux de faire ça sous-estimer comme
ça pourquoi lui prend pas son nom va lui
prendre le pion c4 ça sert à rien ça se
confirme au haut niveau
exactement ce que c'est que je fais une
série de vidéos les échecs en pls où
j'essaye de faire un argument n'importe
quoi je passe t il l'occasion de
regarder le 1 8e
c'est absolument n'importe quoi c'est
pour rigoler c'est pour troller est en
fait maxime faire un peu la même chose
et il ya il ya un abonné qui écrit un
commentaire qui m'a fait marrer parce
qu'en fait figue d'or donc qu'il était
un très grand joueur français au xviiie
siècle était le meilleur joueur du
xviiie siècle
il a écrit dans un livre qui est très
connu le les pions sont l'âme des échecs
il ya un mec qui a mis qui a mis saiki
mai 2016 bleed stream les pions cd c'est
de la merde que tu donnes à ton
adversaire où je suis comme ça je
connaissais de citation ça m'a fait
marrer ou c'est des miettes de pain et
tu lui donnes comme de la merde
enfin quelque chose dans le soutien la
grotte g4 c'est une des ouvertures
fétiche fantastique ce qui bougeait peu
faisait dix longues mais j'ai quatre
fantastiques big up pour maxime quand
même faire une robe c'est bien une
ouverture qu'on aura on essaye de mettre
à la à la mode dans l'eure avec les
vidéos du coup il rend hommage à la
chaîne bitstream tu vois venir au match
non mais si je suis vraiment en fait il
ya enfin je crois
oui je pense pas assez sûr en fait il y
rend hommage avec une robe
il sait qu'on commande soit parti d'un
ouais bien sûr bien sûr il nous rend
hommage
et très content mais at-elle il a
peut-être que mes coups de ces
instruments même quand elle a peut-être
même entendu pour le 12 questions je
sais pas on va lui demander d'attendre
est qu'ils écoutent tout en étant
concentrés sur une partie de championnat
non mais tu as quand même peut-être
qu'il écoutera a posteriori et je peux
at elle pour le 12 questions va après la
grotte on s'attend à tout maintenant tu
as quand même réalisé la chaîne je sais
pas s'ils regardent quotidiennement la
fed mais regarde un petit peu il a même
fait une vidéo d'une heure et demie avec
moi donc un fou en fonte g5 leurs
directs boom mais yalta et qui protège
le cavalier wamen oslo tour vas-y serait
venu en d4 de prendre non mais la grotte
ça fait trop placement c'est une
ouverture que spécifique aux attendes
cavaliers angers 5 et 9 7
il faut fait entre les deux tours on va
espérer on va espérer que ça arrive
allez à il a vu il a empêché
on n'était pas loin de s'imaginer nous
écoute qu'il fait tout ce qu'on lui dit
l'espion de troll ce sera drôle
fantastiquement et c'est un bon troll si
peu trop laid il pas trop les attentats
trop logique aurait pu mettre maxime
troll de niveau 6 je pense que tu es un
troll de niveau 2 niveaux 25 là ce
serait tricher d'écouter les conseils
d'absolu c'est sûr qu'avec moi ces
écoutes mais conseille lui roule dessus
voici donc c'est une ouverture
spécifique à la chaîne ce point là
gravement il ya des gens qui le joue
mais c'est une 10 ouvertures les plus
débiles même
enfin y'a pas longtemps quand je vais
t'aider disant super beast si j'avais
joué là grob maxime et commenter sur sur
facebook que cette ouverture la plume le
coup le plus mauvais qui était jouable
en premier en fait c'est peut-être la
pire ouverture possible
et donc on rigole
les quatre c'est assez marrant c'est
parce qu'il avait joué bobby fischer au
championnat du monde qui avait surpris
tout le monde justement avec cette
ouverture peu commune il avait ouvert
sur un pion une personne s'il attend
d'eux soit disant c'était la partie du
siècle ou je sais pas quoi
[Musique]
c'est la fin de l'hiver
mais bon c'était c4 mais c'est pas une
ouverture et rend pourtant un jeu dans
le film en tout cas je suis plus que moi
ça s'appelle le film qui retrace
l'histoire de bobby fischer ah oui à le
tournage justement quand il joue le
fameux coup tout le monde est stupéfait
tout le monde dit pourquoi il a joué ça
c'est trop bizarre même son adversaire
et comprend pas évidemment il a réussi à
gagner son adversaire l'applaudît tout à
la fin bon
ah tiens regarde surtout reprend dessin
qui a ré cavaliers 7
donc là il peut mettre ça tours angers 4
pour clouer cavaliers voilà hockey
gagner autant en fait le de phoebé 4 h 5
c'est génial maxime fait complètement
n'importe quoi il envoie le pion h et
tout ça il c'est fantastique
tu as envoyé le plus rage comme ça c'est
enfin faut jamais faire ça surtout ne
fait jamais ça ouais bon et qu'il a
gagné avec la grave fabien qu'il y ait
enfin les vrais échecs c'est ça enfin
des vrais effets gaymard défaut échec
non l'esprit à fond mais je tombe jouer
comme ça ça va déstabiliser l'adversaire
et il va gagner encore plus non mais
c'est horrible en fait là grob ambühl
est inclus sais pas si mauvais que ça
assez mauvais en partie longue mais en
bullet tu vois il ya peu de temps
mais c'est génial tu vas il va racheter
il reste combien il reste combien de
temps aux jeunes à s combien de temps je
vais essayer de récupérer le crown rs 10
minutes donc dix minutes il reste on n'a
plus cette
donc normalement il ya déjà même plus de
risques
on n'est même plus en danger de perdre
le match là je pense qu'il va se placer
un petit des quatre cantons
intermédiaire voilà on va aller faire de
la tactique sur fou prend je passe
quelque chose comme tout reprend cahier
prend aidé à me prend 2,5 et là il va
ramener le fou en b 4 font ces cinq sets
ça est un nouveau carnage voilà très
bien je passe il va refaire une fille va
refaire une grob
génial
je pense que s'il ya une seule à alexis
c'est fini mathématiquement complètement
je suis à faire flasher 3 way down 3f
trois pions problème froid et fois je
crois m'être gars ça on se bouffe qui
découpe l'échiquier aller + 8 mai l'art
feu 4 me manquer mais l'autre carte à 6
enfantastiques fantastique
on n'aura pas été des chats noirs 1 mais
pendant un long moment
pendant un moment j'ai pensé qu'on était
deux chats noirs ensemble à qui
commentait un trader
je suis dit ça y est on est là on est en
train de poids c'est maxime
on peut bouger ce cavalier nulle part la
répartition très bizarre achkar atteint
4,6 des pions sont pures 9,5 savate
ouvrir il va peut-être le pousser
maintenant d'ailleurs elle pousse h
centre temps ça ne donne pas mal le
coteau du roi 1 sinon on s'ennuie koné
de 8 est à présent non mais xiang il
peut être content de son match quand
même hein il aura fait un bon match
oui mon avis budget surtout de résister
le plus longtemps possible quoi enfin
oui normalement aucune chance de gagner
mais bon non il aura bien il aura il
leur a vendu chèrement sa peau mais bon
le bullet c'est souvent ça vraiment
comme je me répète un peu mais le joueur
le plus fort souvent il fait la
différence dans cette cadence
nomack s'agit c'est moi ou les deux
joueurs plus c'est moi ou les deux
joueurs s'amusent et je vous prie très
sérieusement je pense exigeons guéret
commence à jouer un peu bizarrement en
bullet et puis après maxime là
maintenant qu'il a pris le score il
jouait un peu bizarre mais quand est
beaucoup plus fort que ton adversaire tu
peux jouer bizarrement tu peux les
mettre en pls en fait
bonjour bizarrement ouais on bizarrement
site est beaucoup plus fort ce que tu
fais en bullet tu peux sur sur la
vitesse de calcul tu peux tu peux y
arriver
pourquoi le pop russo et non à nous
protéger pour le fou c'est un courage
encore
vous prendre pour une qualité de plus
pour xu gang mais bon maxime va essayer
de sentir et de trois le nom de faire
c'est difficile parce que la tour en 1
tu allais bien placé aller loin je peux
pas vraiment faire tu pas vraiment
l'attaqué je pense qu'il va la perdre
celle là je pense que c'est perdu
zhang a gagné mais tant mieux qu'ils
gagnent un petit peu c'est bien pour le
gamin se plaint pour le diamant
non mais c'est vrai toute façon là on a
ça fait un peu pauvre petit l'un prend
une sucette
c'est un peu ça n'empêche qui lui a fait
quelques frayeurs quand même
non mais c'est sûr que quand il a été
mené d'un point on a vu un que il a il a
quand même mis un gros coup
d'accélérateur
on a ville a senti qu'il pouvait
peut-être perdre le match à ce moment là
maxime mais il a mis un coup
d'accélérateur et c'était bon qui me
lisent de trois noms à notre fou mais je
pense que c'est pas un mauvais résultat
franchement sur un match de trois heures
on a vu des tels massacres dans ce blitz
speech est championship avec les joueurs
qui étaient qualifiés qui se sont fait
massacrer par le par le top mondial
exigeons qui résiste quand même très
bien on a vu des écarts de 14 15 16
points un dom de trois autres hôpitaux
un entretien est protégé mais bon il va
il s'approchait que son cavalier
s'approcher que ces pièces je sais pas
pourquoi le gamin c'est bien enfin c'est
un gamin et la saison n'ont pas tu
trouves que c'est peu c'est plus un
gamin tout aussi absolue soit dans le
chat y discute un peu de ça moi ça m'a
juste fait rien ça faisait un peu pauvre
type r quoi mais ces trois bombes ont
pour se consoler nous avons dans deux
ans comme ce deal sera donc dans le top
elle émettra une branlée à tout le monde
d'ailleurs est ce que quand tu vieillis
tu deviens moins bon aux échecs à partir
d'un certain âge suite mais a calculé
moins vite mais ça va être partir de 35
36 ans mais bon tu compenses par
l'expérience et aoued à 35 36 ans de jo
tu calcules -8 partir de finlande à
fabien ce qu'il en pense qu'il ya plus
d'expérience que moi là dessus pour ses
propres sensations mais tu baisse avec
l'âge là que je me disais tu vois encore
les sports physique bon ok c'est normal
mais sport intellectuel je me disais tu
peux être toujours au top niveau même à
40 quoi bon à nantes par exemple tu
appelles tu as plein de grands champions
qui reste qui reste au top jusqu'à 2.3
matt est annoncée pas match quelqu'un
qui est en prison il faut peut-être
faire tour à tour simplement pour faire
un clouage reprend un mois je sais pas
il faut calculer un petit peu il ya
plusieurs moyens de traiter ça avec les
blancs et de gagner c'est de choisir le
plus précis donne sa sobre même il est
obligé c'était le seul coup légal diacre
ami qui a un hangar des joueurs qui
restent au top niveau mais quand même à
partir de 35 48 a quand même du mal à
maintenir à près de tokyo
toi moi j'ai 30 ans va bientôt la
retraite aux grands noms mais il ya des
joueurs des joueurs qui restent au
niveau bien sûr mais c'est ça devient
difficile il faut beaucoup de de
motivation et d'envié
jean pierre polvent cosgrove tout ça car
j'aime le sa retraite donc c'est
différent et quart pour info il ses
filles déjà depuis un moment là il peut
encore prendre le pion au coeur quand ce
satin là ils ne mangent pas assez
options je pense que pai veut pas perdre
de temps avec sa dame
quoi mais après ils menacent le fou quoi
possible il est très bien à g smith la
fia il ya eu pas mal de pas mal de
joueurs qui ont bien joué âgées mais je
parle du commun des mortels la plupart
des joueurs y baissent quand même
jusqu'à 90 ans quand je ne réaliserai
déjà bon en plus il est encore bon en
plus enfin par rapport à tout âge
mais comme il fallait bien y résistent
ils n'atteignent pas leur top ils
essayent de résister le plus longtemps
mais cram nicolas plus fort en dans les
années 2000 c'est sûr après ils se
battent sur l'expérience sur sur
d'autres qualités mais il joue moins
bien
prêt peut toujours avoir des exceptions
au maximum à nouveau un pion plus
pendant qu'on discute de ça on se dirige
peut être vers une nouvelle victoire
donc on est à combien la hâte et avoir
une fourchette ou ça ne fonctionne pas
et c'est déjà passé je joue même pas vu
ça allait oui on aa + 8
donc on est on est dans mon pronostique
un jetage ag annoncé +8 et on se la
rendre aux alentours j'aurais dû parier
je pense qu'il ya des sites pourparlers
sur les chocs
il ya des bookmakers des fois qu'ils
prennent des paris sur les échecs pour
le dernier match de championnat du monde
y avait des paris possibles
genre tu peux parier à combien de points
d'avancé ils vont le devant le barça tu
pouvez parier sur qui allait devenir
champion du monde tu pouvez parier sur
le premier coup qu'ils allaient théâtre
jouée dans la partie tu vois il paraît
sur n'importe que mon truc à elle c'est
génial c'est le premier coup avec fabien
on faisait nos pronos et two way on
pense que tu es le premier coup sera
joué bon ça va faire nul et c'est la
dernière partie donc on a pu suite s'ils
annulent on va finir exactement sur le
score qu'on avait prévu
donc bien à ce qu'ils font
ouais c'est les 960 vous regardent
peut-être le curage à 2 qui peut à
huawei
je peux y arriver allait le prendre
hop
faudrait pas qu'ils bloquent sa haine
encore une fois j'ai entendu dire la
même chose des a perdu exactement 2 dans
le même esprit la dernière fois mais bon
là il a des casses de retrait quand même
mais bon attention petit à petit il y en
a de moins en moins des cases de retrait
oui comme dit fabien ya des joueurs qui
ont fait leurs meilleurs lots tard mais
le hainaut n'y a pas même une inflation
donc c'est pas parce qu'on a un meilleur
look on joue mieux for iphone prendre en
compte l'inflation de lots well et pour
jouer en contre
ouais c'est qu'avant par exemple il ya
une vingtaine d'années un joueur à 2700
il aurait été beaucoup mieux classés
dans le top mondial qu'aujourd'hui oh
ouais faut calculer en rang mondial
plutôt plus quand comme écrit sylvain
plus qu'en et l'eau parce que le vélo en
fait c'est différent fin ça change en
fait plus le temps passe plus les lots
plus et les joueurs ont deux points elo
en fait
bon alors
qu'est ce qu'un ami les mieux classés
que lui en pelote
je pense que je comprends pourquoi je
pense que c'est il ya un bug en fait
puisque l'impression qu'il est plus de
lots il ya prenez nos produits la 2170
quoi c'est parce qu'ils jouent pas
beaucoup sur ce point comme soit assez
mais je comprends pas pourquoi une telle
différence malgré la raclée qu'il ratera
lui m pascal et là il a dû prendre pas
mal de points ah ouais l'atelier and
facile aux 50 points par partie en
gagnant contre quand en 3009 d'imaginer
3900 ça là par contre je pense qu'il va
la perdre et pense avoir un pion un
deuxième un troisième cas c'est le vélo
dès 1960 c'est pour ça a mûri on en 960
ouais donc il faut t4 et il va venir
faire venir échanger les tours et cette
finale là à voir comment ça va finir
il a mis tous ses pions sur les cases
blanches comme ça le foot peut rien
faire oui c'est sûr c'est animé pour
jouer pour la nul à les noirs ils vont
essayer de tout défendre en défendant
les cases noires en fait en défendant
les pions sur noir il va peut-être tenir
souvent ça qui ne changent pas quoi là
il va perdre le curieux 5000 ans c'est
fini
non c'est fini parce que le problème
c'est que si tu si tu prend 1,5 et que
tu échanges en fait le pion le pion en
plus tu vois il finit le travail c'est
ça aussi problème quant à du matériel en
moins c'est que c'est que tu peux plus
échangées en fait ouais mais là pour le
coup je veux le même nombre de pions bas
y avait deux pions pour pour les blancs
en fait à ce moment là de la partie
donc en fait d'engager pas feu en fait
ça a germé de ça permet de donner du
matériel en fait pour rester avec un
pion plus et venir et venir l'épauler
comme on a vu un la petite épaulettes et
eu l'épaule jusqu'au bout bon bah écoute
victoire de victor de mc zorn incombe
bien du coup d'ascète points 19 à 12
c'était juste pour donner tort ouais ce
que suite il n'y a pas de plus elle met
finalement en conclusion on aurait pu
faire mieux mais maxime a fait le
service minimum je pense ouais non mais
c'est des bobos combat c'était un beau
combat c'était sympa et le prochain
match je vais donner je vais donner la
date je sais pas j'ai pas qu'il
commentera de vérifier s'ils ferment
tous les matchs seront commentés en
france air mais il faudra voir comment
se débrouillent je vais juste regarder
non c'est pas ça
c'est ici prochaines dates dans
normalement à titre à titre informatif
ans parce que les dates peuvent changer
au dernier moment comme pour ce match là
mais normalement le prochain match ce
sera donc contre gries tchouk et et le
prochain match sera contre green shoots
et le prochain match ce sera le 12
octobre
non le 5 octobre le 5 octobre avec avec
magnus carlsen qui jouera contre eux
contre un joueur qualifié et il jouera
contre gaillard gousseïnov donc prochain
match 5 octobre
magnus carlsen ou qui bons mots c'était
cool
ouais tenterait une bonne soirée à tous
le monde ouais ouais je sais pas combien
en était d'ailleurs j'ai pu regarder à
chaque fois on était un peu plus de 400
un moment donné ça c'est sûr et 450 500
probable pour un pour un premier tour
ouais non ma vue au final tu as plus de
monde quoi oui plus plus tu plus tu
montes dans les dents les joueurs plus
tu as de dents dans les tours plus tard
de monde et surtout là ce n'était pas un
match le joueur en face était jeune
c'était pas le match le plus attrayant
tu vois en terme d'affichage premier
abord ouais mais finalement il s'est
bien battu
c'était sympa c'était sympa c'était
presque plus intéressant que certains
autres matches il y avait pas mal non
plus élevé ce match a été sympa bon ben
ciao tout le monde salut tout le monde
bonne soirée